Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Modern Ukraine was entirely created by Russia. That was Vladimir Putin in a televised address that he gave on the 21st of February. And Dominic, the Russian president has really been casting himself as a top analyst of Ukrainian history recently, hasn't he? He has indeed, Tom. Obviously, we've been looking forward to doing a podcast about the history of Ukraine for a while. We did think about having a self-styled historian of Ukraine, Vladimir Putin from Moscow, but he's otherwise engaged, it seems, in invading Ukraine. So we're going to do the whole sweep ourselves without his assistance,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果你想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。现代乌克兰完全是由俄罗斯创造的。这是弗拉基米尔·普京在2月21日发表的电视讲话中说的。多米尼克，这位俄罗斯总统最近真的把自己塑造成了乌克兰历史的顶级分析家，不是吗？他确实如此，汤姆。显然，我们一直很期待做一期关于乌克兰历史的播客。我们原本考虑过邀请一位自封的乌克兰历史学家——来自莫斯科的弗拉基米尔·普京，但他似乎忙于别的事，比如入侵乌克兰。所以我们要靠自己把这段历史从头到尾梳理一遍，不需要他的协助，
would you believe? It's an amazingly interesting, convoluted and complicated story, the history of Ukraine. It is, absolutely. And on that line that I began with, modern Ukraine was entirely created by Russia. I mean, that is very important to Putin. Obviously, it provides him with his Kazusbelli, his justification for invading Ukraine. But implicit in our intention to look at the history of Ukraine as something distinct is a kind of rejection of that idea, isn't there uh yes i don't think well we're going to go through the history for you know 1 500 years or so 1 200 years i suppose um but i don't think that history does show that uh ukraine was created by the bolsheviks i don't think it was there's obviously ukrainian national sensibility before that a sense of ukraine is a distinct place um the name name Ukraine means kind of Ukraine, the land on the edge, the kind of
你敢信吗？乌克兰的历史是一个极其有趣、盘根错节且复杂的历史。确实如此。顺着我刚才引用的那句话，现代乌克兰完全是由俄罗斯创造的。我的意思是，这对于普京来说非常重要。显然，这为他提供了“战端”（Casus Belli），即他入侵乌克兰的正当理由。但我们打算把乌克兰的历史视为一个独特的存在，这种意图本身就隐含着对那种观点的拒绝，不是吗？呃，是的，我不认为……嗯，我们要讲的是（你知道的）大约1500年或1200年的历史，我想……嗯，但我认为历史并没有表明乌克兰是由布尔什维克创造的。我不认为它是。在此之前，显然存在着乌克兰的民族意识，有一种乌克兰是一个独特地方的意识……“乌克兰”这个名字的意思是边境之地，某种
borderland. And that's part of Ukraine's problem. But it is not Muscovy. It is not Russia. It is something distinct. And to Vladimir Putin, that is an affront because he thinks it should be part of Russia, that the Ukrainians are little Russians. But as we shall see in the sweep, they have a very entangled, complicated history, rather like Britain and Ireland, actually, or lots of other countries with smaller neighbours. But they are different phenomena. that the reason that this story is very, very complicated, that, you know, as the listeners will find out, there are a lot of partitions, the borders kind of move this way and that, they vanish completely and so on. Do you think that that is essentially what enables Putin to make this case? That Ukraine often, I mean, it hasn't existed as a national entity for long sweeps of time? Yeah, I think there's a lot of truth in that, Tom.
边疆区。这也是乌克兰问题的一部分。但它不是莫斯科公国。它不是俄罗斯。它是一个独特的存在。对于弗拉基米尔·普京来说，这是一种冒犯，因为他认为它应该是俄罗斯的一部分，乌克兰人是小俄罗斯人。但正如我们在这番梳理中所看到的，他们有着非常纠缠、复杂的历史，实际上很像英国和爱尔兰，或者许多其他拥有较小邻国的国家。但它们是不同的现象。这个故事之所以非常非常复杂，你知道的，正如听众们会发现的那样，有许多次瓜分，边界这样或那样地移动，它们完全消失了，等等，你认为这本质上就是普京能够提出这个论点的原因吗？因为乌克兰经常——我的意思是，在漫长的时间跨度里，它并没有作为一个民族实体存在过？是的，我认为这其中有很大的道理，汤姆。
I think it's part of a part of Europe that includes, let's say, Poland or Belarus, where borders have changed a lot, where empires, great empires, have swallowed up nations and then they've disgorged them again at the end. And I think that makes the story much more complicated. And almost every detail of what we'll be talking about is actually contested. So even the names, you know, you and I both call Kiev, well, we think of it as Kiev.
我认为它是欧洲一部分的一部分，其中还包括（比方说）波兰或白俄罗斯，那里的边界发生了很大变化，帝国、伟大的帝国吞噬了各个国家，然后在最后又把它们吐出来。我认为这让这个故事变得复杂得多。而且，我们要谈论的内容几乎每一个细节实际上都存在争议。所以，甚至连名字——你知道的，你我都把基辅叫作……嗯，我们认为它是 Kiev。
As in chicken Kiev, don't we? Exactly, because we're children of the sort of 70s. Of that age. And even the names of the places, the names of the people are contested. So for those of you who are listening kind of poised to complain, we'll probably get them all wrong one way or another, because that's the nature of the beast, actually. I mean, even the very origins of Ukraine have been argued about by historians. Well, Dominic, just before we go back and we start looking at the history of it, two further questions. The first is, do you think our sense
就像“基辅鸡”那样，对吧？没错，因为我们是70年代的孩子。那个时代的人。甚至连地名、人们的名字都存在争议。所以对于那些准备抱怨的听众来说，我们可能横竖都会把它们念错，因为这其实就是这种事物的本质。我的意思是，甚至连乌克兰的起源本身也一直受到历史学家的争论。好吧，多米尼克，在我们回头开始探讨它的历史之前，还有两个问题。第一个是，你认为我们对
of Ukraine as a distinct national cultural entity, that that's been blotted out by the fact that its history in the 20th century was so horrendous, so that we tend to think of its sufferings rather than perhaps of its cultural achievements. Yeah, I think that's a really good point, Tom. We think of Ukraine as part of what the historian Timothy Snyder calls the bloodlands. So kind of Belarus, Ukraine, Lithuania, Poland, places that were fought over by Hitler and Stalin, basically. It's just a sort of colossal blood-soaked battleground. And there is much more to the history than that. But it has to be said, there's an awful lot of terrible suffering in Ukrainian history. I mean, there's a period in
乌克兰作为一个独特民族文化实体的感知，是否被这样一个事实所抹杀：它在20世纪的历史是如此骇人听闻，以至于我们往往倾向于去想它的苦难，而不是它的文化成就。是的，我觉得这是一个很好的观点，汤姆。我们认为乌克兰是历史学家蒂莫西·斯奈德（Timothy Snyder）所称的“血地”（Bloodlands）的一部分。基本上就是白俄罗斯、乌克兰、立陶宛、波兰这些曾被希特勒和斯大林争夺过的地方。它只是一片庞大、浸透鲜血的战场。这段历史远不止于此。但必须说的是，乌克兰历史上确实有大量可怕的苦难。我的意思是，有一个时期在
the 17th century that's just called the ruin. And when you've got a bit of your history that's called that, you know it's not good. And one last question before we plunge into the vast sweep of Ukrainian history. Previously, we did a kind of emergency episode on the history of Afghanistan when the American evacuation happened. So this is the second time that we're responding to great geopolitical events with a kind of emergency episode of this podcast do you i mean how large crisis do you think this is as a historian of of modern britain modern america modern europe and presumably a greater moment of geopolitical crisis than the evacuation of afghanistan by nato yeah i think absolutely a bigger than the evacuation of afghanistan was a humiliation for the Western powers and for the Western kind of model, but it wasn't an existential threat.
17世纪，仅仅被称为“大破坏时期”（The Ruin）。当你的历史有一部分被这样称呼时，你就知道它不会是什么好东西。在深入探讨宏大的乌克兰历史之前，还有一个问题。此前，当美国撤离发生时，我们曾针对阿富汗历史做过一期类似应急的节目。所以这是我们第二次用这种应急播客的形式来回应重大地缘政治事件。你觉得……作为现代英国、现代美国、现代欧洲的历史学家，你认为这是一场多大的危机？这大概比北约撤出阿富汗是一个更大的地缘政治危机时刻吧？是的，我完全这么认为。比从阿富汗撤军要大得多，阿富汗撤军对西方大国和西方模式来说是一种羞辱，但它不是一种生存威胁。
I think it's no exaggeration to say it's the greatest crisis really that probably the world has faced since the Cuban Missile Crisis in 1962. I mean, the comparison that a lot of people make is with the 1930s. It's maybe not massively – I mean's it's it's obviously not quite on that scale but you know um a war in europe that could see tens of thousands hundreds of thousands of people killed could see a huge capital city in kiev be surrounded potentially bombed i mean that's a pretty terrifying prospect and um you know you can see it in the stock market and oil prices. Even if Britain and the Western powers don't become militarily directly sucked in, it will have a huge impact, I would say,
我认为毫不夸张地说，这是自1962年古巴导弹危机以来，世界可能面临的最大危机。我的意思是，很多人做的类比是20世纪30年代。它可能没有达到那么大规模——我的意思是，它显然没有达到那个规模——但是，你知道的，……欧洲的一场战争可能会导致成千上万、数十万人丧生，可能会看到基辅这样的大都市被包围、甚至可能遭到轰炸，我的意思是，这是一个相当可怕的前景。而且，你知道的，你可以从股市和油价中看出这一点。即使英国和西方大国没有在军事上直接卷入其中，我想它也会对普通人的生活产生巨大影响。
on the lives of ordinary people. Right. So the specific measure that Putin announced in his televised speech on Monday was that he was recognizing the independence and sovereignty of the Donetsk People's Republic and the Luhansk People's Republic. And these are regions in the east of Ukraine, very heavily industrialized with a lot of Russian speakers. Previously, he had annexed the Crimea, which had been part of Ukraine, but previously hadn't. I mean, and essentially, the point of this is that the borders are constantly slipping in this area. And you could argue that that's because it has a kind of fundamentally featureless quality,
没错。所以普京在周一的电视讲话中宣布的具体举措是，他承认了顿涅茨克人民共和国和卢甘斯克人民共和国的独立和主权。这些是乌克兰东部的地区，工业化程度很高，有大量俄语人口。此前，他吞并了克里米亚，克里米亚曾经是乌克兰的一部分，但以前不是。我的意思是，本质上，这一点的关键在于，这个地区的边界一直在变动。你可以认为，这是因为它具有一种根本上毫无特色的品质，
the landscape, that it's very difficult to draw borders on it. And do you know, Dominic, the first historian to point this out, how difficult and challenging it was to pin down features to work out where you were if you were roaming around this land. Well, since it's you, Tom, I'm going to guess it's Greek. Is it Greek? Is it the father of history? It is. It's Herodotus. So this is really, this is my big contribution, is that the land that we now call Ukraine first appears in the very first work of history ever written, which is Herodotus' Histories. And he describes the Persian king Darius trying to conquer the Scythians, the people who inhabit that region. And basically the Scythians just run away. And poor old Darius goes kind of harrying around all over the place and he just can't find anything to conquer. And then he withdraws and he abandons Ukraine to the kind of the various nomadic people who had lived there. And essentially that is its history for another, well, certainly another thousand years, thousand years and more,
这里的地貌，很难在上面划定边界。你知道吗，多米尼克，第一个指出这一点（即确定地貌特征是多么困难和具有挑战性，如果你在这片土地上游荡，很难弄清自己身在何处）的历史学家是谁？好吧，既然是你，汤姆，我猜是希腊人。是希腊人吗？是历史之父吗？正是。是希罗多德。所以，这就是我的一大贡献，我们现在所称的乌克兰这片土地，首次出现在有史以来第一部历史著作中，也就是希罗多德的《历史》。他描述了波斯国王大流士试图征服斯基泰人——居住在那片地区的民族。基本上斯基泰人只是逃跑了。可怜的大流士到处追击，却怎么也找不到什么可以征服的东西。然后他撤退了，并将乌克兰抛给那些曾住在在那里的各种游牧民族。本质上，在接下来的又一个——嗯，至少又一个千年、一千年甚至更长的时间里，它的历史就是
is various nomadic peoples occupying it, kind of loose loose vague empires so dominic we actually did um quite recently about a month ago an episode on um the vikings in the east about how um scandinavians came down the niper uh and and established a great capital at kiev um but you remember you remember we had the the froachers pechnegs who were yeah Yeah. The Pechenegs were very fierce. Very fierce. They were cutting off people's heads and turning them into golden drinking vessels. All that kind of stuff. That was absolutely par for the course. Which the Scythians had been doing back in Herodotus' day.
各种游牧民族占领它，建立某种松散、模糊的帝国。所以，多米尼克，其实就在最近——大约一个月前，我们做了一期关于……东欧维京人的节目，讲的是……斯堪的纳维亚人如何顺着第聂伯河而下……并在基辅建立了一个伟大的首都……但你还记得，你还记得我们有那些凶猛的佩切涅格人（Pechenegs），他们是……是的。佩切涅格人非常凶猛。非常凶猛。他们割下别人的头颅，把它们变成金色的饮酒器皿。诸如此类的事情。这绝对是家常便饭。斯基泰人在希罗多德的时代就已经这么做了。
It's just a thing that people say about nomads, isn't it? It is. It's just the sort of standard thing that people say. Yeah, so we did do the Vikings in the East podcast. And that's where the Ukrainian history, and indeed, I mean, this is how complicated it is, and indeed Russian history often begins. So it begins with, for those people who didn't listen to those Viking episodes, the Vikings, before they came, actually pretty much just before they came west
这只是人们对游牧民族的一种说法，对吧？确实如此。这只是人们的一种标准说法。是的，所以我们确实做过“东欧维京人”这期播客。乌克兰的历史——实际上，这也是它有多么复杂的地方——甚至俄罗斯的历史往往就是从这里开始的。所以它是从……对于那些没有听过维京人节目的听众来说，维京人在他们来到西方、
to England and battled, you know, the Anglo-Saxons and Alpha the Great, they went east and they went down the rivers, down the Dnieper and the Volga. And this fellow called Rurik, legend has it, was asked to come into Novgorod by the local Slavs and basically sort it all out and install sort of the firm smack of government. And then some pals of his or some sort of cronies, Askold and Deer, they went off and founded Kiev. And then one of Rurik's, another sort of crony of his
前往英格兰并与（你知道的）盎格鲁-萨クソン人以及大帝阿尔弗雷德战斗之前，实际上几乎就在那之前，他们去了东方，顺着河流而下，顺着第聂伯河和伏尔加河。传说有一个叫留里克（Rurik）的家伙，应当地斯拉夫人的邀请来到诺夫哥罗德，基本上把这一切都整理好了，并建立了一种坚定的政府管理方式。然后他的几个伙伴或亲信，阿斯科尔德（Askold）和迪尔（Dir），他们出发建立了基辅。然后留里克的另一个亲信——
who was the sort of regent for Rurik's son, Igor, a man called Oleg, he went and captured Kiev. And basically that sort of bit of Viking feuding started this state, which you know a lot about, Tom, which is Kievan Rus. And that's where we get Russia, the word Russia from. Yeah, but it's ruled from Kiev. Yeah. So Kiev, which I think had actually existed before they arrived.
留里克儿子伊戈尔（Igor）的摄政王，一个名叫奥列格（Oleg）的人，他去占领了基辅。基本上，维京人的这种内部争斗开启了这个国家，这是一个你非常了解的国家，汤姆，也就是基辅罗斯（Kievan Rus）。“俄罗斯”这个词就是从这里来的。是的，但它是从基辅统治的。是的。所以基辅，我想要在他们到达之前就已经存在了。
It was a kind of Slav town, hadn't it? Yeah, it was a kind of fort on a hill. But it becomes the center of this kind of increasingly, I dare one say, civilized empire, because it starts to take on the influence of Byzantium, of Constantinople to the south. It has this vast sweep of lands reaching right the way up to nov grod and beyond so huge in scale um and uh i think one could safely say that the chief feature of this um of this uh empire is the incredibly entertaining deaths of its rulers so there's according according to the the sources which are not all they could be uh there was one there's a guy who uh gets tied up
它是一个类似斯拉夫城镇的地方，对吧？是的，它是一座山上的堡垒。但它逐渐成为这个日益发展的帝国中心——我敢说这是一个文明的帝国，因为它开始吸收南方的拜占庭、君士坦丁堡的影响。它拥有广袤的土地，一直延伸到诺夫哥罗德及更远的地方，规模宏大，而且……嗯，人们可以有把握地说，这个……这个……帝国的最大特色就是其统治者极其戏剧性的死亡。所以，根据……根据那些并非十全十美的史料记载，有一个家伙……他被绑在
between two uh fir trees that have been pulled down and then they cut the fir trees and they bang and he spits in two and then there's you made the same noise in the full podcast tom very good to see you keeping the same noise and then there's another guy who um kicks the skull of his horse and a snake comes out and bites him yeah but um they're also very proficient so um there's saint olga who you know becomes a saint but also big fan of hers and she um she firebombs um refractory uh local towns by unleashing burning sparrows on them and then of course, there is Vladimir, who is the Ukrainian prince who converts to Christianity. When you say Ukrainian, he's Rus. They're called the Rus, aren't they?
两棵被拉弯的冷杉树之间，然后他们砍断冷杉树，轰的一声，他被劈成了两半。然后在完整版的播客里你也发出了同样的噪声，汤姆。很高兴看到你保持了同样的音效。然后还有另一个家伙，他……踢了自己战马的头骨，一条蛇钻出来咬了他。是的……但他们也很能干。所以……有圣奥尔加（Saint Olga），你知道她成了一位圣人，但同时我也是她的超级粉丝，她……用火攻……袭击了那些桀骜不驯的当地城镇，方法是把燃烧的麻雀放生到城里。然后当然还有弗拉基米尔，他是皈依基督教的乌克兰亲王。当你说是乌克兰人时，他是罗斯人。他们被称为罗斯人，对吧？
Because for those people who didn't listen to the last podcast. So they're called the Rus because the root means kind of rowers, doesn't it? Oarsmen. Yeah, going down the rivers yeah and the lakes so that's what they're so what they're sort of creating is it's a sort of it's not quite maritime isn't quite there but it's a riverine empire of trading stations and the focus of it which makes it no longer viking in the long run is constantinople that's the place you go to sell all your stuff. And that's the sort of great economic and cultural magnet.
因为对于那些没有听过上一期播客的听众来说。所以他们被称为罗斯人，因为这个词根的意思是划船者，对吧？桨手。是的，顺着河流……是的，还有湖泊。所以这就是他们所创造的——这是一种……虽然“海上”这个词不太准确，但它是一个由贸易站组成的河流帝国。而它的重心（这从长远来看使它不再具有维京特色）是君士坦丁堡，那是你去兜售所有货物的地方。那是巨大的经济和文化磁石。
And you mentioned Vladimir. When he converts to orthodoxy, he has a great auction, doesn't he? Is auction the right word? He basically sends people out to go check out the Muslims and the Jews and all these different religions, And he chooses orthodoxy. And that is the defining moment in creating East Slavic kind of culture, because orthodoxy becomes the big thing. Dominic, you mentioned Slavic.
你提到了弗拉基米尔。当他皈依正教时，他进行了一场大拍卖，对吧？“拍卖”这个词对吗？他基本上派人去考察穆斯林、犹太人和所有这些不同的宗教，然后他选择了正教。这是创造东斯拉夫文化的分水岭时刻，因为正教成了最重要的事情。多米尼克，你提到了斯拉夫。
I mean, that's also the other great thing, isn't it? That if these Viking chieftains gradually become ever more Slavic, and the parallel that we mentioned in the fuller length episode we did was the Dukes of Normandy becoming ever more French. So it's that kind of process that the distinctively Nordic quality of these princes of Kiev gets kind of swallowed up. So you have Vladimir who, you know, very classy. He marries the sister of the Byzantine emperor.
我的意思是，这也是另一个伟大的事物，对吧？如果这些维京首领逐渐变得越来越斯拉夫化，我们在完整版节目中提到的相似之处就是诺曼底公爵变得越来越法国化。所以这是一个过程，基辅这些亲王们独特的北欧特质被逐渐吞没了。所以你有了弗拉基米尔，你知道的，非常高档。他娶了拜占庭皇帝的姐妹。
So that's no barbarian prince had ever pulled that stunt off before and then his son yaroslav who starts off as yaroslav the lame and then ends up yaroslav the wise which is the measure of how well he does i made the same joke that i made last time he's upwardly mobile for a for a lame man he's upwardly mobile very good very good um and he i said i mean he starts laying down law codes um all the kind of stuff that you need as a go-getting um 11th century uh christian monarch and then it starts to slightly fall away doesn't it yeah so it's a sort of it's definitely a state of a kind by that point um kiev and rus it's it's huge geographically it's probably not
在此之前，从来没有哪个蛮族亲王能玩出这种把步。然后是他的儿子雅罗斯拉夫（Yaroslav），他一开始被称为“跛子雅罗斯拉夫”，最后变成了“智者雅罗斯拉夫”，这证明了他干得有多好。我开了和上次一样的玩笑：作为一个跛子，他很有上升空间。他很有上升空间，非常好，非常好……而且他——我说过，他开始制定法典……所有这些作为一个蒸蒸日上、充满进取心的11世纪基督教君主所需要的东西。然后它开始有点走下坡路了，对吧？是的，所以到了那个时候，它绝对是一个某种意义上的国家——基辅罗斯。它的地理面积巨大，可能没有
as co it's not as sophisticated as the eastern roman empire as byzantium it's not as coherent as let's say anglo-saxon england is at the same time more frank here france um but yeah it's a it's a big entity it's a big and important european entity and it's marrying into royal right uh european royalty it is I'd say. It is European. There's absolutely no doubt about that. Kievan Rus is definitely European in the sense that there is a kind of a Europe.
东罗马帝国（拜占庭）那么精致。它不像当时的盎格鲁-萨クソン英格兰那样连贯，或者说不如法兰克法国……但是的，它是一个庞大的实体，一个庞大且重要的欧洲实体，它与欧洲皇室联姻。它是的，我要说。它是欧洲的。毫无疑问。基辅罗斯绝对是欧洲的，在这个词意味着存在某种欧洲的意义上。
It's part of the same constellation. It's part of the world of Christendom, all that stuff. But you're right. It starts to go into decline in the 11th, 12th, 13th centuries. Part of this actually is, you know, we mentioned about Constantinople being the big magnet. It's partly because Constantinople itself is having a tough time in these years,
它是同一个星群的一部分。它是基督教世界的一部分，诸如此类。但你是对的。它在11、12、13世纪开始走向衰落。部分原因实际上是——我们提到君士坦丁堡是一块巨大的磁石——部分原因是君士坦丁堡本身在这些年里也过得很艰难，
particularly after the Crusades, which are responsible for so much misery in the world. When they sack Constantinople in 1204, that's very bad news for Kievan Rus because Constantinople is where they settle their stuff. That's very bad news for Kievan Rus, because Constantinople is where they settle their stuff. That's their destination. And that puts more pressure on. And also, the Kievan rulers have a very strange system where when one dies, it's not necessarily the oldest son that succeeds.
特别是经历了给世界带来如此多痛苦的十字军东征之后。当他们在1204年洗劫君士坦丁堡时，这对基辅罗斯来说是个非常坏的消息，因为君士坦丁堡是他们安顿货物的地方。这对基辅罗斯来说是个非常坏消息，因为君士坦丁堡是他们安顿货物的地方。那是他们的目的地。这带来了更大的压力。而且，基辅的统治者有一个非常奇怪的制度：当一人去世时，并不一定由长子继承，
It's just the next eldest person in the whole family. So that just makes it endless. Yeah, because if there's like one person- Family feuds. Older than you, you just kill them. But as soon as you're the oldest, you have to watch your back. So there's a terrible-
而只是家族中最年长的人。所以这就导致了无休止的……是的，因为如果有一个人……家族内讧。比你年长，你只要杀了他。但一旦你成了最年长的人，你就得提防后背。所以有一场可怕的……
Yeah, it doesn't make for a good Christmas. There's a terrible amount of feuding. And even before the arrival of some very colorful characters from the East, who we'll come to in a second, even before that, there is a sense that Kiev is losing a bit of momentum to two other rivals that are both in what is now Russia. So one is Novgorod, which is of longstanding. And the other is a principality called Vladimir Suzdal,
是的，这不利于过个好圣诞节。有数量惊人的可怕内讧。甚至在一些来自东方的、我们一会儿就会谈到的性格鲜明的人物到来之前，甚至在那之前，人们就有一种感觉：基辅正在失去一点势头，正面临着位于现俄罗斯境内的另外两个竞争对手的挑战。一个是历史悠久的诺夫哥罗德。另一个是一个名为弗拉基米尔-苏兹达尔（Vladimir-Suzdal）的公国，
which is nearer to Moscow, which is sort of central Russia. So it's sort of losing a bit of momentum. And then we have these characters who all the listeners will have heard of called the Mongols. Yeah. And generally when the Mongols turn up. That's bad news. It's not good news, is it? And they turn up outside Kiev in 1240? They do. So the Mongols, I know we'll have some new listeners because it's a newsworthy subject. So if you enjoy what you're listening to, we have a podcast coming up in a few weeks just about Genghis Khan and theongols i think the mongols i think are pretty poorly behaved so they turn up outside kiev in 1240 and they sack kiev i mean they're basically as they do to every city that defies them they they sack it they absolutely tear everything down
它更靠近莫斯科，也就是俄罗斯中部。所以它的势头有点在减弱。然后我们就有了这些所有听众都听说过的人物，叫做蒙古人。是的。一般来说，当蒙古人出现时……那可不是好消息。这不是什么好消息，对吧？他们在1240年出现在基辅城外？他们确实来了。所以蒙古人——我知道由于这是一个具有新闻价值的主题，会有一些新听众——如果你喜欢你正在收听的内容，我们在几周后会有一期关于成吉思汗和蒙古人的播客。我认为蒙古人……我觉得他们的行为相当糟糕。所以他们在1240年出现在基辅城外，洗劫了基辅。我的意思是，基本上就像他们对待每一个反抗他们的城市一样，他们洗劫了它，彻底摧毁了一切，
they kill i think 50 000 people and destroy out of that of out of you know 40 big buildings they they tear down 34 of them. They basically utterly level Kiev. And after that, the power of Kievan Rus is utterly, utterly broken. The state basically is destroyed. And that, the coming of the Mongols, I think, is such an important moment in this story because Kievan Rus, which occupied what was now Ukraine, is broken. And the big rising power is a grand duchy that basically is a client of the Mongols,
他们杀害了（我想）5万名居民，在许多大建筑中，他们摧毁了34座。他们基本上把基辅彻底夷为平地。在那之后，基辅罗斯的力量被彻底、彻底地打破了。这个国家基本上被摧毁了。而蒙古人的到来，我认为是这个故事中如此重要的一个时刻——占据了现代乌克兰所在土地的基辅罗斯破碎了。而正在崛起的大国是一个大公国，它基本上是蒙古人的附庸，
is a vassal of the Mongols and a kind of intermediary of the Slavs. And that is a place called Muscovy, Moscow. And that's going to be the genesis of Russia. So you get a slight, it's also Orthodox. It's got the same Slavic culture, but it's a different kind of pole to Kiev. But also, I mean, in the 14th century, by the 14th century, if we're looking at Kiev and Riz, what it's been, what's going to become Ukraine, it's basically divided three ways, right? So the Mongongols the brilliantly named golden horde the golden horde imagine it's absolutely my favorite horde if you
是蒙古人的藩属，也是斯拉夫人的某种中介。那个地方被称为莫斯科公国（Muscovy）、莫斯科。这将是俄罗斯的起源。所以你会得到一个稍微不同的……它也是正教。它拥有相同的斯拉夫文化，但它是与基辅不同的另一个权力中心。但同时，我的意思是，在14世纪，到14世纪时，如果我们看看基辅罗斯，它曾是什么样，什么将成为乌克兰，它基本上被三方瓜分了，对吧？所以蒙古人——
were gonna have a horde you'd call it the golden horde wouldn't you yeah i'd go for the golden horde every time yeah um and and then uh poland which of course is catholic yeah um and then there's another duchy which is the grand d Duchy of Lithuania. Yeah, such an interesting subject. So longstanding listeners will know that we promised about 18 months ago that we would do a podcast about the history of Poland and Lithuania, the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth, because it's such a strange state. But basically, yes, you've got the – well, there's the Golden Horde, and that sort of evolves or devolves or sort of degenerates
拥有那个极其拉风名字的“金帐汗国”（Golden Horde）。金帐汗国，想象一下，绝对是我最喜欢的汗国。如果你非要有一个汗国，你就会叫它金帐汗国，对吧？是的，我每次都会选金帐汗国。是的……然后……波兰，当然它是天主教的……是的。然后还有另一个公国，那就是立陶宛大公国。是的，这是一个非常有趣的主题。所以老听众会知道，我们在大约18个月前曾承诺过，我们要制作一期关于波兰和立陶宛历史的播客——波兰-立陶宛联邦，因为它是一个如此奇怪的国家。但基本上，是的，你有——嗯，有金帐汗国，它演变或退化
into basically a Crimean carnate. So Crimea is this peninsula that juts out into the Black Sea and there's a carnate based on Crimea. And that's where the Black Death originally comes to Western Europe because there's a siege there and they supposedly fire bodies and all that kind of stuff. That's right. Exactly right. And then you've got a bit that's run by the Poles.
成了基本上是克里米亚汗国。所以克里米亚是一个伸入黑海的半岛，那里有一个以克里米亚为基地的汗国。黑死病也就是从那里最初传到西欧的，因为那里发生过一次围城战，据说他们把尸体发射过去，诸如此类。完全正确。完全正确。然后你有了波兰人控制的一部分。
And then you've got a bit that is taken over by Lithuania. And Lithuania is a very strange place because it's a massive, massive realm. But it's quite sort of – it's not immensely sophisticated by European standards. And it's still pagan at this stage. And it's pagan. Yes.
然后你有了被立陶宛接管的一部分。立陶宛是一个非常奇怪的地方，因为它是一个庞大无比的国度。但它相当……按欧洲标准来看，它并没有极其精致。而且在这个阶段它仍然是异教。它是异教。是的。
So interesting. It's the last pagan redoubt in in in europe um but then in 1385 lithuania and poland basically have a dynastic alliance they're not they're not they're still separate they're a bit like scotland and england james friend of the show james the first with his big tongue um so poland and lithuania have the same king who is vladislav jagiel and he announced thank you my polish is top notch um so uh so they become they have the same ruling kind of elite or the same king rather and then in 1569 they finally become united in one commonwealth the polish lithuanian
太有趣了。这是欧洲最后的异教据点……但在1385年，立陶宛和波兰基本上达成了王朝联盟。他们不是——他们仍然是分开的，有点像苏格兰和英格兰，节目之友詹姆斯一世带着他那大大咧咧的舌头……所以波兰和立陶宛拥有同一个国王，也就是瓦迪斯瓦夫·雅盖沃（Vladislav Jagiello）。他宣布……谢谢，我的波兰语棒极了……所以……所以他们拥有相同的统治精英或同一个国王。然后在1569年，他们最终联合成了一个联邦，即波兰-立陶宛
commonwealth and actually if you look at a map of the polish lithuanian commonwealth almost all of present-day ukraine is part of that it's not which is all the way to the black sea doesn't it yeah it's actually all the way to the back sea it's not part of so it's again it is absolutely not part of muscovy at this point it does have a separate distinct history yes it's not part of so it's again it is absolutely not part of muscovy at this point it does have a separate distinct history yes it's slavic yes it is orthodox but it is um it is ruled and actually what ends up happening is that what becomes belarus belongs to the grand duchy lithuania that part of the commonwealth and what becomes uk becomes Ukraine belongs to the kingdom of Poland. So that's partly how Belarus and Ukraine have separate identities.
联邦。事实上，如果你看一下波兰-立陶宛联邦的地图，几乎所有现今的乌克兰都是其中的一部分。它没有……一直延伸到黑海，对吧？是的，它实际上一直延伸到黑海。它不是……所以它再次绝对不是此时莫斯科公国的一部分。它确实有着独立、不同的历史。是的，它是斯拉夫的，是的，它是正教的，但它是……它是被统治的。实际上最后发生的情况是：成为白俄罗斯的土地属于立陶宛大公国（联邦的那一部分），而成为乌克兰的土地则属于波兰王国。这也是白俄罗斯和乌克兰拥有不同身份的部分原因。
And then basically the story is kind of, you know, they've got Polish overlords. And the Poles are Catholic. They are, exactly. And the Ukrainians are Orthodox. So what kind of tensions are building up there? Big tensions, Tom. You love a religious tension. I do.
然后基本上这个故事就是……你知道的，他们有波兰领主。而波兰人是天主教徒。他们确实是，完全正确。而乌克兰人是正教徒。那么那里正在酝酿什么样的紧张局势呢？巨大的紧张局势，汤姆。你最喜欢宗教紧张局势了。我确实喜欢。
So all you have is, we're going forward now. The Commonwealth was created in 1569, so in the 16th, 17th centuries. And you have to imagine it's very, very rural. It's kind of flat, rural territory. These huge landed estates with Polish elites, Catholic elites. The Polish later call it the Kresi, which is the edge lands. That gives you a sort of sense of how people have often thought of Ukraine. You mentioned Herodotus and the borders, this idea of being a constant fracture zone,
所以你所拥有的就是——我们现在要向前推进了。这个联邦创建于1569年，所以在16世纪、17世纪。你必须想象它是非常非常乡村化的。它是一种平坦的乡村领地。这些由波兰精英、天主教精英统治的庞大庄园。波兰人后来称之为“克雷西”（Kresi），意为边缘之地。这让你对人们如何看待乌克兰有了一种感觉。你提到了希罗多德和边界，这种作为持续断裂带、
a kind of border zone. It doesn't mean it doesn't have a distinct identity of its own, but it means there's always people fighting over it. Anyway, the Poles, as you say, are Catholic. What come to be called Ukrainians, so the word that people use before Ukraine is Ruthenians, which obviously comes from Kievan Rus. And they continue to use that word, don't they? I mean, in Austria and Hungary and all that kind of thing, the word Ruthenian continues to mean Ukrainian up until the 19th century, is it?
某种边界地带的概念。这并不意味着它没有自己独特的身份，但这意味着总有人在争夺它。无论如何，如你所说，波兰人是天主教徒。后来被称为乌克兰人的群体——在“乌克兰”这个词出现之前人们使用的词是“鲁塞尼亚人”（Ruthenians），这显然来自基辅罗斯。他们继续使用这个词，对吧？我的意思是，在奥地利、匈牙利和所有这些地方，“鲁塞尼亚人”这个词一直到19世纪都继续意味着乌克兰人，是这样吗？
Yeah, early 20th century, Tom. Early 20th century early 20th century definitely absolutely and there are still people who are called who are called russians um in kind of the carpathian mountains to this day people who call themselves russians um so from russ anyway so they are um orthodox as you say but they're ruled by uh kind Catholic overlords. And what you have, which is really interesting, is that in 1596, basically, they do a deal with the Vatican, because obviously religious identity is so important. And the deal is that they will create their own sort of church within Catholicism that is both Orthodox and Catholic. Who's doing this? The Ukrainian nobles? The sort of, yes, exactly.
是的，20世纪初，汤姆。20世纪初……绝对是的。而且在喀尔巴阡山脉，至今仍有人被称为——被称为俄罗斯人，那些自称为俄罗斯人的人……无论如何，从“罗斯”而来……所以他们正如你所说，是正教徒，但他们受制于……天主教领主的统治。而你所拥有的、非常有趣的是，在1596年，基本上，他们与梵蒂冈达成了一项交易，因为宗教认同显然太重要了。这笔交易是，他们将在天主教内部建立自己的某种教会，既是正教又是天主教。是谁在这么做？乌克兰贵族吗？可以说是……是的，完全正确。
The religious elites in what is now Ukraine. So it's called the Uniate Church. So basically it's a Catholic church. It's under the jurisdiction of the Pope, but they get to keep their Eastern Rite. They get to keep their Slavonic liturgy and they get to have married clergy even, which Catholics aren't normally allowed. So in other words, it looks like an Orthodox church, but it's under Catholic suzerainty.
现今乌克兰境内的宗教精英。所以它被称为“乌合教会”或“东仪天主教”（Uniate Church）。所以基本上它是一个天主教教会。它受教宗管辖，但他们得以保留他们的东方礼仪。他们得以保留斯拉夫礼 liturgy，甚至还可以拥有允许结婚的神职人员，而天主教徒通常是不允许的。换句话说，它看起来像一个东正教教会，但它处于天主教的宗主权之下。
And that becomes a huge dividing line for the next 300 years or so, because the Russians, who are obviously Orthodox, when they end up ruling Ukraine, they don't approve of the Uniate Church at all. They're completely against it because they see it as anti-russian yes and also at the same time isn't it about kind of 1580 that um a kind of great cultural center is founded um and it has a printing press and i think the first bible in slavonic is published there so it's this you're starting to get the sense of this distinctive dare we call it ukrainian yet i mean that well that's kind of anachronistic anachronistic but but a distinctive religious culture a distinctive um intellectual culture
而在接下来的大约300年里，这成了一条巨大的分界线，因为俄罗斯人（他们显然是东正教徒）最终统治乌克兰时，他们一点也不赞成东仪天主教教会。他们完全反对它，因为它被视为反俄的……是的，而且与此同时，大约在1580年左右，不是吗？……建立了一个某种伟大的文化中心……它拥有印刷机，我想第一部斯拉夫语《圣经》就是在那里出版的。所以你开始有一种感觉，这种独特地——我们现在能叫它乌克兰吗？我的意思是，这有点……年代错置，但一种独特的宗教文化、一种独特的……
is starting to emerge yeah you know and it's and it's the end of the 16th century which is a time where this is happening across europe so again this is part of a you know it's not specific to to you know to this eastern half of europe it's happening in london it's happening in france it's happening all over the place right amsterdam that's the story is not as you say absolutely it's not a unique story um they are a definite there are people with their own kind of folkloric traditions their own religious traditions and so on and as you say through printing and that will become a much bigger thing obviously through literacy in the 19th century, they're getting a sort of sense of themselves, of their own distinctiveness. But there is one other element that I think is pretty unique. Yes. So I was going to ask you about that.
知识文化开始涌现。是的，你知道的，这是16世纪末，这是一个全欧洲都在发生这种事的时期。所以再次强调，这是（你知道的）一部分，它不是东欧这半部分所特有的。它正在伦敦发生，正在法国发生，正在各处发生，对吧？阿姆斯特丹……故事并非如你所说——完全正确，这不是一个独一无二的故事。他们是一个明确的群体，拥有自己独特的民间传统、宗教传统等等。正如你所通过印刷术所说的那样——随着19世纪识字率的提高，这将会变得更加重要——他们正在获得一种关于自身、关于自身独特性质的意识。但还有一个因素，我认为是相当独特的。是的。所以我正要问你这个。
You don't know what it is, Tom? Or do you? Well, I do. Would it be the Kazakhs? It is. The adventurers, the freemen that we know as the cossacks it is exactly very good so yeah the word kazakh is turkish and as you say i mean it's kind of outlaw kind of freebooter um lad yeah sort of soldier of fortune um and what basically happens are is that in this area of sort of what is now southwestern Ukraine, sorry, southeastern Ukraine, there are these places that the Poles call the wild fields.
你不知道那是什么吗，汤姆？还是你知道？嗯，我确实知道。会是哥萨克人吗？正是。我们所知的那些探险家、自由民，也就是哥萨克人。正是，非常好。所以“哥萨克”这个词是突厥语，正如你所说，我的意思是，它有点像法外之徒、自由掠夺者……小伙子，有点像……命运战士。基本上发生的情况是，在这个现在的西南部乌克兰——对不起，东南部乌克兰的地区，有一些波兰人称之为“荒野之地”的地方。
There's these big sort of open steps. And over time, runaway serfs, exiled nobles, bandits, outlaws, they end up kind of taking refuge in these great sort of open grasslands where their enemies or the sort of Muscovites or the Polish authorities can't catch up with them. I mean, it's a bit like a kind of Wild West in America, American West. Except that they're gathering honey. Yeah. It's a lovely detail.
这里有大片大片开阔的草原。随着时间的推移，逃亡的农奴、被流放的贵族、强盗、法外之徒，最终都在这些广阔开阔的草地上避难，在这里，敌人、莫斯科人或波兰当局无法追捕到他们。我的意思是，这有点像美洲的某种狂野西部。除了他们在收集蜂蜜。是的。这是一个可爱的细节。
They are. They're beekeeperskeepers they're frustrated beekeepers so they end up in this they go to the lowered nipa there's a phrase which means beyond the rapids so beyond the rapids of the lowered nipa and um it's zaporochi and the place ends up being called zaporozhia and they become known as the sort of the Zaporozhian host. I'm sure I'm pronouncing that wrongly, by the way, so don't bother. My Ukrainian is as bad as my Russian. Let's put it that way. Should we just say the Cossacks?
他们确实在收集。他们是养蜂人……他们是受挫的养蜂人。所以他们最终来到了这个地方，他们去了第聂伯河下游——有一个短语意思是“急流之外”。所以越过第聂伯河下游的急流……那是扎波罗热（Zaporozhia），这个地方最终被称为扎波罗热。他们被称为“扎波罗热军团”（Zaporozhian host）。顺便说一句，我确信我把这个词发音错了，所以不用介意。我的乌克兰语和我的俄语一样糟糕。我们干脆就说哥萨克人好了？
Yeah. Well, we should do, but I think the fact that they're a host. We've had a horde. I think you've got to have a host as well. Yeah. So they're not uniates. They are orthodox. And they're very, they're kind of answerable only to themselves. And they're very kind of volatile and fierce and stuff.
好吧，我们应该这么说，但我觉得他们是一个军团（host）这一事实……我们已经有了“汗国”（horde），我觉得你也得有一个“军团”。是的。所以他们不是东仪天主教徒。他们是正教徒。他们非常……他们只对他们自己负责。他们非常多变、凶猛之类。
And they have, they hate, they don't like the polls. They don't like being bossed around by the polls. Are they a proud and freedom loving people? They are. They're a bit like those, who are those fellows in Game of Thrones? The Dothraki. The Dothraki. There's a bit of a kind of Dothraki.
而且他们有……他们讨厌、他们不喜欢波兰人。他们不喜欢被波兰人颐指气使。他们是一个骄傲且热爱自由的民族吗？他们是的。他们有点像那些……《权力的游戏》里的那些家伙是谁？多斯拉克人。多斯拉克人。有点多斯拉克人的感觉。
I mean, the Dothraki are also kind of native American. In which case, they're a throwback to the Scythians and the tradition of nomadic people. I think they absolutely are. Almost self-consciously, actually, Tom. They have this sort of, we won't, you know, there's a sort of libertarian element, anarchic element to them. And a very important figure, actually a massively important figure in this history, I shouldn't undersell him, is a Cossack leader called Bogdan Khmelnytsky. I'm sure I've pronounced that very poorly.
我的意思是，多斯拉克人也某种程度上是美洲原住民。那样的话，他们就是对斯基泰人和游牧民族传统的一种回归。我想他们绝对是，实际上几乎是有意为之的，汤姆。他们身上有一种……某种自由主义元素、无政府主义元素。而一个非常重要的人物——在这个历史中具有极其重要的人物，我不能低估他——是一个名叫博格丹·赫梅利尼茨基（Bogdan Khmelnytsky）的哥萨克领袖。我确信我把这个名字发音得很糟糕。
I noticed you're not pronouncing any of these names. Well, I knew that his name was coming. So I've been practicing it all morning. And you never got to say it. No. So this guy, go on, tell us about him. Bogdan Chmielnicki. So he leads a rebellion against the Poles,
我注意到你没有发音任何这些名字。好吧，我知道他的名字要出现了。所以我一整个早上都在练习。而你根本没机会说。没有。所以这家伙，说下去，跟我们讲讲他。博格丹·赫梅利尼茨基。因此，他在1654年领导了一场反对波兰人、反对哥萨克波兰地主的起义，这是一个极其重要的日期。整个故事中真正重要的日期之一。顺便说一句，这比赫鲁晓夫将克里米亚移交给乌克兰早了300年。他这样做是故意选择这个时刻的周年纪念日。因此，赫梅利尼茨基在这个时刻（1654年）与俄罗斯沙皇达成了协议。而该协议的细节一直遭到俄罗斯和乌克兰历史学家的激烈争论。好吧。那么普京会怎么说呢？普京会说，赫梅利尼茨基和哥萨克人同意，作为换取俄罗斯援助以对抗
against the Polish kind of landowners of Cossacks in 1654, which is an incredibly important date. One of the really important dates in this whole story. It's 300 years, by the way, before Khrushchev will give Crimea to Ukraine. And he does that deliberately because it's the anniversary of this moment. So Khmelnytsky reaches a deal with the Russian Tsar at this point, 1654. And the details of that deal have been argued about very ferociously by Russian and Ukrainian historians. Okay. So what would Putin say about it? Putin would say Khmelnytsky and the Cossacks agreed that in return for Russian aid against
波兰人的回报，他们基本上将成为俄罗斯沙皇的藩属臣民。并且从这一刻起，生活在乌克兰南部和东部的哥萨克人就受制于莫斯科的宗主权。那么乌克兰人会怎么说呢？乌克兰人会说，不，那不对。协议的内容是，我们将与俄罗斯人结盟，我们可能会以非常模糊的方式承认他们为宗主国，但我们将拥有我们自己的首领（被称为盖特曼，hetman）、我们自己的领导人、我们自己的安排，我们应该能够进行我们自己的外交关系。而我
the Poles, they would be basically vassal subjects of the Russian Tsar. And that from this point onwards, the Cossacks living in southern and sort of eastern Ukraine were subject to the overlordship of Moscow. And what would Ukrainians say? Ukrainians would say, no, that's not right. The deal was that we would be allied to the Russians and we would maybe acknowledge them in a very vague way as overlords but we would have our own chief called a hetman our own leader we'd have our own arrangements we would have be able to conduct our own foreign relations and i'm
没有资格告诉你这些版本哪个是准确的。在某种程度上，汤姆，我想这其实并不重要，哪个才是真正准确的——如果曾经有过的话。重要的是人们现在赋予它们的意义。俄罗斯人认为这是乌克兰臣属于莫斯科的证据。而乌克兰人则说，不，这是我们独立的时刻。所以，多米尼克，这发生在1654年。与此同时，在英国和爱尔兰，正是护国公时期，克伦威尔的护国公时期，他的军队基本上在残酷对待爱尔兰，很大程度上将其并入英格兰的控制之下。克伦威尔还将苏格兰置于英格兰的控制之下。这其中是否有某种类似的过程？
not qualified to tell you which of those versions is accurate and in a way tom i suppose it doesn't really matter which is which is truly accurate if, it was. What matters is the meaning that people give them now. Russians see this as proof that Ukraine is kind of subject to Moscow. And Ukrainians say, no, this is a moment of our independence. So, Dominic, this is happening in 1654. At the same time in Britain and Ireland, this is when the protectorate, Cromwell's protectorate, his troops are essentially brutalising Ireland, very much kind of annexing it to English control. Cromwell has also brought Scotland under English control. Is there a kind of similar process there?
你认为这是一种未成形的国家建构过程吗？你知道吗，汤姆？这不是一个坏的类比。显然，它绝不是一个精确的类比。但是，当我在阅读这段历史并为这期播客做准备时，我确实经常想到与英国和爱尔兰的关系。而且，你知道的，那种历史相互交织但
Do you think a kind of inchoate process of state formation? Do you know what, Tom? It's not a bad analogy. I mean, obviously it's not an exact analogy by any means. But I did, when I was reading this story and preparing for this podcast, I did think quite often about the relationship with Britain and Ireland. And, you know, that sort of sense of having very much intertwined histories but but still distinct but distinct exactly that it's
又截然不同、却又分明的感觉，恰恰如此。
the same thing you know it would be mad now it would be mad to deny that britain and ireland have an incredibly tangled history but it would equally be mad to deny or to the island is different that it has its own identity and its own kind of flavor its own historical narrative um and so would it be an exaggeration to say that the way that ukrainians feel now about russian claims that that ukraine is part of russia would be like the irish might feel if suddenly someone in britain said you know you're part of the united kingdom i think you're exactly right, Tom. That's exactly what I thought.
同样的道理，你知道，现在如果否认英国和爱尔兰有着极其错综复杂的历史，那绝对是疯了；但同样地，如果否认或不承认这个岛屿与众不同，它有自己的身份、自己的特色和自己的历史叙事，那也是疯了。嗯，那么，乌克兰人现在对“乌克兰是俄罗斯一部分”这种俄罗斯主张的感受，就像当年如果英国有人突然说“你知道吗，你是联合王国的一部分”，爱尔兰人可能会有的感受一样，这么说会不会太夸张了？汤姆，我觉得你说的完全对。我当时也是这么想的。
That's, I mean, it's funny that we both thought the same thing because we didn't, we're a bit like, this is a bit like when Putin said to his men on Monday, we absolutely haven't discussed this beforehand. You will now tell me what you think. So this is, I mean, we genuinely haven't discussed this beforehand. And this is exactly what I thought, that it is rather like somebody from,
我的意思是，我们俩想法一样这挺逗的，因为我们之前并没有——我们有点像普京周一对他手下说的那样：“我们绝对事先没有讨论过这个。你们现在要告诉我你们是怎么想的。”所以，我是说，我们真的事先没有讨论过这个。而这正是我所想的，这就有点像某个……
if somebody in 21st century Britain said to somebody from Limerick, you're not actually Irish because that's not a thing. You're all British. I mean, it would be unthinkable, wouldn't it? It would seem demented. Although, of course, there are people in Ireland who do say they're British. So again, that's a- But I don't think they would deny, I don't think even they would deny that there is such a thing as being Irish. I think the implication of the more extreme kind of Putinist interpretation is that basically Ukrainians are just a form of Russians.
如果21世纪的英国有人对利默里克的人说：“你实际上不是爱尔兰人，因为根本没这回事。你们全都是英国人。”我的意思是，这简直不可想象，对吧？听起来太疯狂了。当然，爱尔兰也确实有人说他们是英国人。所以说，这又是一个——但我认为他们不会否认，即使是他们也不会否认存在“爱尔兰人”这种身份。我认为更极端的普京式解释的潜台词基本上是，乌克兰人不过是俄罗斯人的一种变形。
But it's just that if we think that the complexities of Russian speakers who perhaps are sympathetic to what Putin's doing in the eastern regions of Ukraine. This is all weird stuff that has nothing to do with us. And you just have to look at Northern Ireland to see the historical legacy of different traditions, different rulers, all that kind of stuff. Well, just on that, just on the language thing, it was really interesting. Actually, Volodymyr Zelensky, the president of Ukraine, is a Russian speaker.
但问题是，如果我们认为，那些可能同情普京在乌克兰东部地区所作所为的俄语使用者，他们的复杂心态——这一切都是些跟我们没关系的怪事。你只需要看看北爱尔兰，就能看到不同传统、不同统治者等等的历史遗留问题。嗯，说到这个，就语言而言，其实非常有趣。实际上，乌克兰总统弗拉基米尔·泽连斯基就是一位俄语使用者。
And actually, being a Russian speaker does not automatically mean you are pro-Russian. Rather like, actually, in Ireland, being an English speaker doesn't mean you crave unity with the United Kingdom. Anyway, maybe, Tom, we should have a break now and we should return with... The Ruin. The Ruin, exactly. So don't go away.
而且实际上，身为俄语使用者并不自动意味着你亲俄。其实有点像在爱尔兰，英语使用者并不意味着你渴望与联合王国统一。总之，汤姆，也许我们现在该休息一下，然后回来继续讲……《废墟》。对，《废墟》。所以别走开。
We will be back with The Ruin. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free
我们将带着《废墟》回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐而已》。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告
listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest is history to um a special edition we are doing on ukraine prompted of course by um current events um dominic when we left we had arrived at the cossacks yeah and the great cossack chieftain kamil ninsky oh come on tom that was poor kamil ninsky yeah who has um signed a treaty with Muscovy, the rising power of Muscovy. The exact terms of that treaty remain contested to this day. But he's a potent, imposing figure leading this kind of almost independent Cossacks state in the area of what's now Ukraine. But things go very rapidly wrong. And this is the
收听、独家单集以及抢先获得现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史而已》来收听我们关于乌克兰的特别节目，当然，这是由当前的事件引发的……多米尼克，我们刚才讲到哥萨克人。是的，还有伟大的哥萨克酋长赫梅利尼茨基。哦，得了吧，汤姆，赫梅利尼茨基这个梗太冷了。是的，他与莫斯科——正在崛起的莫斯科势力——签署了一项条约。该条约的具体条款至今仍有争议。但他是一个强有力、威风凛凛的人物，在现在乌克兰的土地上领导着几乎独立的哥萨克国。但事情很快就出了岔子。这就是
period that Ukrainians know as the ruin. So what is so ruinous about the ruin? Well, there are two moments in Ukrainian history that are just, even by the standards of Ukraine in history, dementedly complicated. The ruin is one and the period just at the end of the First World War is the other. So the ruin, the 17th century is a horrendous period generally because it's a sort of little ice age, global kind of cooling, famine everywhere, religious conflict everywhere. And what happens in the Ukrainian version of that is the thing called the ruin, the Poles call it the deluge. Basically everybody fights everybody. So the Cossacks fight each other, the Cossacks fight the peasants, the Poles are involved, the Russians are involved, the Crimeans are involved, the Ottomans are involved. There are all these sort of rival armies doing deals with other people long story um short at one point ukraine's kind of
乌克兰人所知的“大灾变”时期。那么，“大灾变”到底有什么灾难性的？嗯，乌克兰历史上有两个时期，即使按乌克兰历史的标准来看，也复杂得令人发指。“大灾变”是一个，第一次世界大战结束时的那个时期是另一个。所以，“大灾变”所在的17世纪总的来说是一个可怕的时期，因为那是一种类似小冰河时期、全球变暖降温、各地闹饥荒、到处都是宗教冲突的时期。而在乌克兰版的这段历史中发生的事情就叫“大灾变”，波兰人称之为“大洪水”。基本上就是所有人都在跟所有人打仗。哥萨克人内讧，哥萨克人打农民，波兰人卷入其中，俄罗斯人卷入其中，克里米亚人卷入其中，奥斯曼人卷入其中。所有这些形形色色的敌对军队都在跟别人做交易。长话短说，嗯，在某个时刻，乌克兰的领土被
partitioned along the line of the river denipa so the poles get the western half what's called the right bank and the russians get the the other half the left is that the is that the hilariously named treaty of eternal peace i think it is the treaty of eternal peace um it doesn't quite live up to its billing. The most inaccurately named treaty of all time. Exactly. I mean, what basically happens is in central and eastern Ukraine, you have the Cossack Hetmanate, the sort of Cossack state.
沿第聂伯河一线瓜分了。所以波兰人得到了西部的一半，也就是所谓的“右岸”，俄罗斯人得到了另一半，即左岸。那是那个名字极其滑稽的《永久和平条约》吗？我想是的，就是《永久和平条约》。嗯，它有点名不副实。史上名字最名不副实的条约。没错。我的意思是，基本上发生的情况是，在中部和东部乌克兰，你拥有了哥萨克酋长国，也就是那种哥萨克国家。
I wouldn't want to be a Cossack Hetman. Well, well. So that's top Cossack, basically. The top Cossack is a man called Ivan Mazepa. He's very famous. Friend of the show. Very controversial. So that's top Cossack, basically. The top Cossack is a man called Ivan Mazepa. He's very famous. Friend of the show. Very controversial. Because we, Dominic, we did a whole series of the top 10 times that the weather has influenced history, didn't we? And Mazepa featured in that.
我可不想当哥萨克酋长。嗯，嗯。所以那就是“头号哥萨克”，基本上。头号哥萨克是一个名叫伊万·马泽帕的人。他非常有名。本节目的老朋友。非常有争议。所以那就是“头号哥萨克”，基本上。头号哥萨克是一个名叫伊万·马泽帕的人。他非常有名。本节目的老朋友。非常有争议。因为我们，多米尼克，我们曾做过一整期节目盘点天气影响历史的十大时刻，对吧？马泽帕就在其中出场了。
I'd forgotten we did. Yeah, we did. The Great Northern War. In the Great Northern War. Between the Swedes and the Russians. So at one point, just when you think Ukrainian history couldn't get any more complicated and more important. The Swedes turn up. The Swedes get stuck in.
我都忘了我们做过了。对，我们做过。大北方战争。在大北方战争中。瑞典人和俄罗斯人之间。所以有那么一段时间，就在你觉得乌克兰历史不可能变得更复杂、更重要的时候。瑞典人出现了。瑞典人卷了进来。
Basically, what happens is that Mazepa clearly dreams of an independent Ukrainian state. He wouldn't have called it Ukrainian. They're not using that word. But he dreams of a state on that territory. He's been allied to Peter the Great, the sort of colossal and very, as we discovered in our parties podcast, very poorly behaved, very bad house guest, Peter the Great. Don't sublet to a seven-foot tall czar. So he's been allied to Peter the Great.
基本上，发生的事情是，马泽帕显然梦想着建立一个独立的乌克兰国家。他不会称之为乌克兰人。他们当时不用这个词。但他梦想在那片领土上建立一个国家。他曾与彼得大帝结盟，彼得大帝是个身材高大、而且正如我们在我们的派对播客中发现的那样，行为极其糟糕、是个很差劲的留宿客的彼得大帝。千万别把房子转租给七英尺高的沙皇。所以他曾与彼得大帝结盟。
He turns against Peter the Great and basically does a deal with Peter the Great's implacable arch enemy, Charles the 12th of Sweden. And they're fighting the Great Northern War for control. Who's going to be the top dog? Who's going to be the superpower of the sort of North? Which is such a great name for a war. It is. If you're going to have a war. But if you're going to have a horde, it's going to be golden.
他背叛了彼得大帝，基本上与彼得大帝不共戴天的死敌——瑞典的查理十二世做了交易。他们为了争夺控制权而进行大北方战争。谁将成为老大？谁将成为北方的超级大国？这作为战争的名字真是太棒了。确实。如果你要打一场战争的话。但如果你要有一群人的话，那它就得是金帐。
If you're going to have a war, it should be Great Northern. I think. Yeah. So this is a great, great episode for brilliant names it is and they fight charles the 12th and peter the great and even mazepa they have this great showdown um at a place called poltava in 1709 one of the great decisive battles of european history that most people in britain have never heard of um it is won by the r. Mazepa and Charles XII of Sweden are comprehensively defeated. And from that point on, really, most of Ukraine just ends up in the Russian imperial
如果你要打仗，那就该叫大北方战争。我觉得是这样。是的，所以这是一期充满绝妙名字的极好的节目。确实如此。他们与查理十二世和彼得大帝作战，甚至马泽帕也在1709年在波尔塔瓦这个地方进行了一场大决战。这是欧洲历史上最具决定性的战役之一，但英国的大多数人从未听说过。它由——马泽帕和瑞典的查理十二世被彻底击败。从那时起，实际上，乌克兰的大部分地区最终都落入了俄罗斯帝国的势力范围。
orbit. Now Mazepa, really interestingly, he's an absolute hate figure for the Russians. And for centuries, Russian Orthodox churches, they were just going to curse his name on the first Sunday in every Lent, Mazepa, this terrible villain. But in Ukraine now, he is something of a hero. So his face adorns the 10 hryvnia note. He's a sort of pioneer of patriotic independence movements and all this sort of thing. Which is one of the reasons why Byron wrote about him. Right. Byron wrote an entire poem about him.
现在说到马泽帕，非常有趣的是，他是俄罗斯人绝对痛恨的人物。几个世纪以来，俄罗斯东正教教堂总是在每个大斋期的第一个主日诅咒他的名字：马泽帕这个可怕的恶棍。但在现在的乌克兰，他有点像个英雄。所以他的头像印在10格里夫纳纸币上。他是爱国独立运动的先驱之类的人物。这也是拜伦写过他的原因之一。没错。拜伦写了一整首关于他的诗。
That I did not know, Tom. Your knowledge of Byron obviously is second to none. Well, it's all set in the aftermath of the Battle of Poltova and Mazepa tells the story of his life to cheer Charles up. Oh, that's nice. And it's a very good poem. It involves him being tied to a horse and being sent galloping naked across the the steps well i don't know did that happen in real life i don't know you're not i know you're not sure about that okay but but you know for the appeal of him for
这个我不知道，汤姆。你对拜伦的了解显然无出其右。好吧，这首诗的背景是波尔塔瓦战役之后，马泽帕讲述他的人生故事来让查理高兴起来。哦，那挺好的。这是一首非常好的诗。内容包括他被绑在马背上，赤身裸体地被赶着在草原上飞奔。好吧，我不知道，这在现实中发生过吗？我不知道，我知道你对此不确定。好吧，但你知道，他吸引
byron is that he's a figure of national independence of you know explosive energy all that kind of stuff that byron was as well so um we're starting to get into the age now, aren't we, of the kind of the romantic sense that peoples have a national essence. Exactly. And we're getting towards the age of nationalism, I suppose. But Ukraine at this point does not obviously exist as anything like a nation state. So it's still the Hetmanate, right? It's still the Hetmanate, exactly. Most of it is absorbed into the Russian Empire
拜伦的地方在于，他是一个民族独立的化身，拥有爆发力的能量，诸如此类拜伦也具备的特质。所以，嗯，我们开始进入这个时代了，不是吗？也就是人们开始拥有民族本质这种浪漫主义观念的时代。没错。我想我们正在走向民族主义时代。但在这一点上，乌克兰显然不作为任何类似民族国家的东西存在。所以它仍然是酋长国，对吧？它仍然是酋长国，没错。它的大部分被吞并进俄罗斯帝国，
and its Hetmanet nature is basically being whittled away. Its autonomy is whittled away and Catherine the Great basically abolishes it. At the same time, the other bit of Ukraine that we haven't really talked about, which is Crimea and the bit just by Crimea ends up being
而它的酋长国性质基本上被一点点削弱了。它的自治权被侵蚀，叶卡捷琳娜大帝基本上将其废除了。与此同时，我们还没有真正谈到的乌克兰的另一部分，也就是克里米亚以及紧邻克里米亚的那部分，最终成为了
that's the Crimea incarnate and it has been since the collapse of the Golden Horde. Catherine the Great annexes that in 1783. She calls it Novorossiya, New Russia. That incidentally is how Vladimir Putin sometimes talks about it. He basically says, you know, it's New Russia, it's part of Russia. This is places like Odessa or Dnipro, kind of big Ukrainian cities. And Catherine the Great settles newcomers there, so Russians and Ukrainians, in place of the kind of Tatars who had lived there before.
也就是克里米亚本身，自金帐汗国崩溃以来一直如此。叶卡捷琳娜大帝在1783年将其吞并。她称之为“新俄罗斯”（Novorossiya）。顺便说一句，弗拉基米尔·普京有时就是这样谈论它的。他基本上说，你知道，这是新俄罗斯，这是俄罗斯的一部分。这些地方就像敖德萨或第聂伯罗，都是乌克兰的大城市。叶卡捷琳娜大帝在那里安置了新移民，也就是俄罗斯人和乌克兰人，以此来取代之前住在那里的一类鞑靼人。
But Dominic, there's another region of what will become Ukraine as well, isn't there? Galicia. Yeah, that's still Polish. So that's still part of Poland. But then towards the end of the 18th century, Poland vanishes and gets cut up. So we should say, actually, Ukraine is not alone in having this very tangled, convoluted history where bits of it keep disappearing and reappearing, because exactly the same thing is happening with Poland and indeed with other European countries as well they do um i'm sure you must have seen them kind of get them on youtube or whatever where they show national borders in europe kind of moving at a very fast speed so you know 20 20 years every second or something exactly and if you look at eastern
但多米尼克，未来将成为乌克兰的领土，还有另一个地区，对吧？加利西亚。对，那仍然是波兰的。所以那依然是波兰的一部分。但随后在18世纪末，波兰消失了并被瓜分。所以我们应该说，实际上，乌克兰并不是唯一一个拥有这种非常纠结、错综复杂的历史、其领土不断消失又重现的国家，因为波兰以及其他欧洲国家也发生了完全相同的事情。它们确实如此，嗯，我确信你一定在YouTube或其他地方看到过那种展示欧洲国家边界以极快速度移动的视频，你知道的，每秒钟过去20年左右，完全是这样。如果你看看东欧，
europe far more than in western europe it's absolutely bewildering it is because because empires have come from nowhere spread across you, you know, half the continent, vanish again, get divided up. And essentially, this is what Ukraine has suffered. This is exactly what happened. So Portugal is always Portugal. It's always in the same place. Well, until it gets swallowed up by Spain and then it comes back again. Whereas Poland is kind of moving around all over the place on that map.
远远甚于西欧，那绝对是令人眼花缭乱的。确实如此，因为帝国不知从哪里冒出来，横跨了你所知道的半个大陆，然后又消失，被瓜分。本质上，这就是乌克兰所遭受的苦难。这正是所发生的事情。所以葡萄牙永远是葡萄牙。它总是在同一个地方。好吧，直到它被西班牙吞并，然后又复国。而波兰在那张地图上到处乱移。
Sometimes it exists, sometimes it doesn't. Sometimes it's just in the wrong place completely. Well, Ukraine, yes, the Western bit, Galicia, is Polish. And basically what ends up happening is Poland itself is absorbed. Most of modern-day Ukraine ends up being Russian in the Russian Empire, and Galicia belongs to Austria-Hungary. Now, if you look at any map of Ukraine on linguistic, economic, political voting, and all these kinds of things, Galicia, the Western bit, always is slightly more different or more extreme than other parts of the
有时它存在，有时它不存在。有时它完全出现在错误的地方。嗯，乌克兰，是的，西部地区加利西亚是波兰的。基本上最终发生的情况是波兰本身被吞并了。现代乌克兰的大部分最终变成了俄罗斯帝国的一部分，而加利西亚则属于奥匈帝国。现在，如果你看任何一张关于乌克兰的语言、经济、政治投票以及所有这类事情的地图，加利西亚，即西部地区，总是比该国的其他地区略有不同或更加极端。
country. That's the bit around Lviv. And Lviv itself looks like a Polish or Central European city. And that is the bit that the Americansicans when they withdrew their embassy from kiev i think a couple of you know a few days ago last week perhaps that's the region they went to yeah exactly that's where persistently whenever there's trouble with russia that's where ukrainians have tended to go to that the galician end of ukraine because it's the it's the most sort of central european rather than eastern european kind of end of Ukraine. It has been said, I don't know how true this is, that apocryphally Putin is supposed to have said at one point, I don't know if he said it to George W. Bush or he said it to one of the leaders of Poland, why don't you just take that bit and I'll take the rest
那就是利沃夫周边的地区。利沃夫本身看起来就像一座波兰或中欧城市。这就是当美国人几天前或上周从基辅撤出他们的大使馆时——我想大约是几天前——他们去的那个地区。是的，没错，每当与俄罗斯发生麻烦时，乌克兰人往往就会去那里，去乌克兰的加利西亚那一头，因为那是乌克兰最偏向中欧而不是东欧的一端。曾经有人说，我不知道这有多大真实性，传说普京曾在某个时候说过——我不知道他是对乔治·W·布什说的，还是对波兰的某位领导人说的——“你们为什么不干脆把那部分拿走，剩下的我来拿，
because Ukraine isn't really a country. I mean, that's actually not right. Ukraine clearly is a country. As you see from what happens in the 19th century. So in the 19th century, the bit that is Russian. Which is most of it. Which is most of it. The Russians make a huge attempt to Russify it.
因为乌克兰根本算不上一个国家。”我的意思是，这其实是不对的。乌克兰显然是一个国家。正如你在19世纪所看到的那样。所以在19世纪，属于俄罗斯的那部分——也就是大部分。也就是大部分。俄罗斯人对其实行了大规模的俄罗斯化。
I mean, we talked about how Catholic and the Great and Novorossiya. So they really tried to suppress the Uniate Greek Catholic Church. They want everyone to be Orthodox. They tried to suppress Ukrainian language. What's also happening is that parts of Ukraine, specifically the Donbass, which is the area that is in the news right now, so Donetsk, basically, that becomes very, very industrial. We did a podcast, Tom, about Anglo-Ukrainian relations when England played Ukraine in Euro 2020, even though it was held in 2021. And we talked about how Donetsk was founded by a man called Hughes, a Welshman. And we culturally appropriated him,
我的意思是，我们讨论过叶卡捷琳娜大帝和“新俄罗斯”。所以他们真的试图镇压乌克兰希腊天主教联合教会。他们希望每个人都信仰东正教。他们试图压制乌克兰语。与此同时发生的事情是，乌克兰的一些地区，特别是顿巴斯——也就是现在上新闻的那个地区，基本上就是顿涅茨克——变得非常非常工业化。汤姆，我们做过一期播客，讲的是当英格兰在2020年欧洲杯（尽管是在2021年举办）对阵乌克兰时的英乌关系。我们谈到了顿涅茨克是由一个叫休斯的威尔士人建立的。我们对其实行了文化挪用，
didn't we? We did, because we claimed he was English. Well, we didn't. No, we didn't. But Welsh listeners will never forgive us for that. No, they won't. But right. And that's actually an interesting parallel with Wales, because what happened in Wales in exactly the same period was that lots of English speakers, English people, flooded into South Wales to work in the coal mines and the steelworks. And at the same time, exactly the same time, Russian speakers are flooding into this part of Ukraine to work in the steel factories and the coal mines and all those kinds of things.
对吧？我们确实这么做了，因为我们声称他是英国人。呃，我们没有。不，我们没有。但威尔士听众永远不会原谅我们这一点。不，他们不会。但是，对。这其实与威尔士有一个有趣的相似之处，因为在完全相同的时期，威尔士发生的事情是，大量的英语使用者、英国人涌入南威尔士，在煤矿和钢铁厂工作。与此同时，在完全相同的时期，俄语使用者正涌入乌克兰的这一地区，在钢铁厂、煤矿和所有这类地方工作。
So it's the same thing. That's why the Donetsk People's Republic and the Luhansk People's Republic that Putin's just recognised, that's why there's such support because there are so many Russians there. Well, there are Russians. There are unquestionably some, whether there are majorities is a very fraught question. But there are definitely,
所以这是一回事。这就是为什么普京刚刚承认的顿涅茨克人民共和国和卢甘斯克人民共和国会有如此多的支持，因为那里有那么多的俄罗斯人。好吧，确实有俄罗斯人。毫无疑问有一些，至于是否存在多数，这是一个非常棘手的问题。但绝对有，
I mean, there are definitely a majority of Russian speakers, but whether a majority of pro-Russian kind of Putinists, that's a different matter. Of course, of course. But in general, the cities, the towns, the industrializing towns are more russified. They are, agreed. And it's the countryside that is the kind of... So the peasantry is still kind of Ruthenians, which the word Ukraine is beginning to be used in the 19th century.
我的意思是，绝对有大多数是俄语使用者，但至于其中大多数人是否是亲俄的普京主义者，那是另一回事了。当然，当然。但总的来说，城市、城镇、走向工业化的城镇更加俄罗斯化了。是的，同意。而乡村则是那种……所以农民基本上还是鲁塞尼亚人，在19世纪，“乌克兰”这个词开始被使用。
And the universities are really key as well, because in the universities and in sort of liberal intellectual circles, you have exactly the same thing in Ukraine that you have in Germany or what becomes Germany, in Italy, in Poland, in Ireland, frankly, later on, in what becomes the Czech lands. So a sense of rediscovering a kind of folklore, slightly, is it an invention of a national story? It's not, I think invention is too strong. And also great writers, right? So there's Taras Shevchenko. Yeah, exactly. The great mid-90th century writer who is a peasant.
而且大学也非常关键，因为在大学和自由派知识分子圈子里，乌克兰发生的事情与德国或后来的德国、意大利、波兰、爱尔兰（坦率地说，还有后来的捷克地区）发生的事情完全一样。也就是说，有一种重新发现某种民间传说的感觉，稍微有点像在虚构一个民族故事？我不认为“虚构”这个词太贴切。还有伟大的作家，对吧？比如塔拉斯·舍甫琴科。是的，恰好。19世纪中叶的伟大作家，他出身农民。
So he, that's terribly important, isn't it? It's the idea of the authentic peasant consciousness rising up from the soil and giving voice to these deep, primordial national instincts that reach back centuries and centuries and centuries. Tom, you mentioned Ireland before. Anybody who's read W.B. Yeats will be very familiar with this idea that there are this kind of, there are the people of the soil, you know, who've been downtrodden and oppressed.
所以他，这极其重要，对吧？这就是那种纯朴的农民意识从泥土中升腾而起，为这些历经数世纪之久的深层原始民族本能发出声音的理念。汤姆，你之前提到了爱尔兰。任何读过W.B.叶芝作品的人都会非常熟悉这种观点：这里有一种……有这样一群饱受践踏和压迫的泥土上的人民。
And now they've discovered their kind of national voice. And that's exactly what Shevchenko represents. So he writes about romantic stuff about the Cossacks, about how great they were. He writes about how terrible the Tsars are. Yeah, and the Tsars are- Lots of folklore, lots of, you know, about how great they were. He writes about how terrible the Tsars are. Yeah, and the Tsars... Lots of folklore, lots of, you know, all that kind of stuff. He is, exactly.
现在他们找到了他们的民族之声。这正是舍甫琴科所代表的。所以他写了关于哥萨克人的浪漫主义题材，写他们曾经是多么伟大。他写了沙皇是多么可怕。是的，还有沙皇——大量的民间传说，大量关于他们如何伟大的内容。他写了沙皇是多么可怕。是的，沙皇……大量的民间传说，所有这类东西。他确实如此。
And the Russians are very down on him. So the Tsars... Yes, well, not surprisingly. Alexander II in 1876, he bans Ukrainian books, he bans Ukrainian recitals in the Ukrainian language, he bans Ukrainian in education. It's very... I mean, this is about the point. Maybe it's it's very i mean well this is about the point
而俄罗斯人非常看低他。所以沙皇——是的，好吧，这并不奇怪。1876年的亚历山大二世，他禁止乌克兰语书籍，禁止用乌克兰语进行朗诵，禁止在教育中使用乌克兰语。这非常……我的意思是，这大约是这个时间点。也许时间稍微早了一点点，但这大约是人们开始使用“乌克兰”、“乌克兰人”而不是“鲁塞尼亚人”这个词的时期，
maybe it's a tiny bit early but this is about the point when people are you beginning to use the word ukraine ukrainian rather than ruthenian um and in a way that's because they want to cast off the idea that they're just little russians they're not just other russians they've got their own distinct history and they they want to you know, to celebrate it and stuff. But this tradition of repression of Ukrainian national consciousness, national language, all that kind of stuff, the kind of Putinist approach, as so often, goes back to the Tsars, right? It is. It's a Russian Tsarist approach. Absolutely it is.
从某种意义上说，这是因为他们想要摆脱自己只是“小俄罗斯人”的想法，他们不仅仅是其他俄罗斯人，他们有自己独特的历史，他们想要（你知道的）去庆祝它等等。但是这种对乌克兰民族意识、民族语言等一切的镇压传统——那种普京式的做法，就像往常一样，可以追溯到沙皇时期，对吧？确实如此。这是一种俄罗斯沙皇式的做法。绝对是的。
You stamp down on ukrainian language ukrainian literature all that kind of stuff and so what you get in this period as again later is that you get ukrainian writers fleeing to lviv and to exactly they do because in galicia in the austrian bit um i mean the austrians aren't massively keen on this either i mean they try to stamp it down a little bit but they try to stamp it down in a very kind of half-hearted kind of way compared with the russians um so the russians are all kind of whips and siberia yeah austrians are all cross marches through snow their austrians are all like fancy uniforms and cream cakes and mozart yeah they're doing what you'd rather have yeah and now sometimes my um my editor wrote a book about my editor at penguin wrote a book about
你压制乌克兰语、乌克兰文学以及所有这类东西，所以在这个时期，正如后来的情况一样，你会发现乌克兰作家逃往利沃夫以及——确实如此，因为在加利西亚（奥地利控制的那部分）——我的意思是，奥地利人对此也不是非常热心，我的意思是他们也试图稍微压制一下，但与俄罗斯人相比，他们的压制方式非常敷衍，所以俄罗斯人全是皮鞭和西伯利亚，而奥地利人全是雪地里的阅兵。奥地利人就像华丽的军服、奶油蛋糕和莫扎特。是的，他们做的正是你更愿意接受的。现在，有时我的——我的编辑写了一本关于——我在企鹅出版社的编辑写了一本关于
um the hapsburg ember and he said i was much too indulgent on the Austrians and that actually they could be pretty strict themselves. But I still think, like you, Tom, I'd take my chances in a Viennese coffeehouse before a Russian prison. So anyway, yes, there's definitely Ukrainian sentiment among the intelligentsia, and there's definitely a sense among the peasantry that they are something. They are not just Russians before the First World War. Right. And so we're nowires, you know, going to generate quite a lot of upheaval, most notably in Sarajevo. But before that, you have a kind of group of students, of activists, people like that, the revolutionary Ukrainian party, who in 1900 published a pamphlet that for the very first time
哈布斯堡帝国的书，他说我对奥地利人太纵容了，实际上他们自己也可以相当严厉。但我仍然认为，像你一样，汤姆，我宁愿去维也纳的咖啡馆碰碰运气，也不愿进俄罗斯的监狱。所以无论如何，是的，知识分子中间绝对存在乌克兰情绪，农民中间也绝对有一种他们是某类人的意识。在第一次世界大战之前，他们不仅仅是俄罗斯人。没错。所以我们现在正走向……你知道的，这将会引发相当多的剧变，最引人注目的就是在萨拉热窝。但在那之前，你有一群学生、活动人士之类的人，比如革命乌克兰党，他们在1900年发表了一份小册子，历史上第一次
states as a political goal that there should be one single, indivisible, free, independent Ukraine. The first year of the 20th century, there it is. And that's in Kharkiv, Tom, which is actually now right in the firing line of a potential Russian invasion. And it's one of those cities that, you know, Putinists say ought to be Russian is really Russian. And the fact that's coming from there is quite telling, I think. So obviously, yes, there was the sentiment before the First World War, and then the First World War completely turbocharges it. Actually, really interestingly, what happens when the Russians... In the first year of the First World War, the Russians make great headway against the Austrians in the first few months. And when they go into Galicia, which has been this kind of motor of Ukrainianism, it's so telling. What do they do? They shut it all down. They try to suppress it. They try to shut down the Union Church. They banned the use of Ruthenian. But obviously, then the Germans and the Austrians drive them back. And basically, the Russian war machine ends up falling apart in 1917. And if you thought the ruin was complicated, what happens between 1917 and 1922 in Ukraine, I mean, it's not just complicated, it's completely bonkers.
将建立一个单一的、不可分割的、自由的、独立的乌克兰作为政治目标。20世纪的第一年，它就在那儿了。那是在哈尔科夫，汤姆，而哈尔科夫现在正处于潜在俄罗斯入侵的战火线正中央。它正是那些普京主义者认为应当属于俄罗斯、真正属于俄罗斯的城市之一。这种声音从那里发出来相当说明问题，我认为。所以很明显，是的，在一战之前就有这种情绪，然后一战彻底为其按下了涡轮增压。实际上，非常有趣的是，当俄罗斯人发生……在一战的第一年，俄罗斯人在头几个月对奥地利人取得了很大进展。当他们进入加利西亚——一直以来这是乌克兰主义的发动机——时，这太说明问题了。他们做了什么？他们把这一切都关停了。他们试图镇压它。他们试图关闭乌克兰联合教会。他们禁止使用鲁塞尼亚语。但显然，随后德国人和奥地利人将他们赶了回去。基本上，俄罗斯战争机器在1917年土崩瓦解。如果你觉得“大灾变”很复杂，那么1917年至1922年间在乌克兰发生的事情，我的意思是，不仅复杂，而且完全是疯狂的。
Incomprehensible. So there's, I'll tell you, I tried to make a list at one point. There's a Ukrainian People's Republic. There's a West Ukrainian People's Republic. There's a Bolshevik Soviet Republic. There's an anarchist group as well. There's a hetmanate. There's a directorate. The Germans are there at one point.
不可理喻。所以有，我告诉你，我曾经试图列一个清单。有一个乌克兰人民共和国。有一个西乌克兰人民共和国。有一个布尔什维克苏维埃共和国。还有一个无政府主义者集团。有一个酋长国。有一个督政府。德国人在某个阶段也在那里。
The Poles are there. The White Russian Army are there. So it's, I mean, you have multiple, multiple armies. And to give you a sense of this, all of this, by the way, is missing in Vladimir Putin's recital of history that he did on TV. He basically says, oh, the idea of Ukraine was created by the Bolsheviks, but he misses out the fact that at the end of the First World War, there's this obvious tremendous resilience of the Ukrainian idea because there are all these different people trying to set up a Ukrainian state. So they really do, lots of different people clearly believe in a Ukraine. But Dominic, wouldn't it be fair to say
波兰人在那里。白卫军也在那里。所以，我的意思是，你有无数支军队。为了让你对这一切有个概念——顺便说一句，弗拉基米尔·普京在电视上发表的历史陈词中完全没有提到这一切。他基本上说，哦，乌克兰的想法是由布尔什维克创造的，但他忽略了一个事实，即在第一次世界大战结束时，乌克兰理念有着显而易见的巨大韧性，因为有这么多不同的人在试图建立一个乌克兰国家。所以他们确实，许多不同的人显然都相信乌克兰的存在。但是，多米尼克，难道不可以说
that also that an understanding of this is missing from most people in the West? I mean, certainly basically until I looked at this from my understanding of the period, because for us in the West, you have the First World War and then it stops. But basically the horror for Ukraine is that the period of horror that is initiated in 1914, I mean, it doesn't stop for decades and decades and decades. Because essentially what had been the First World War mutates into the Russian Civil War. But Russia at this point includes a large chunk of Ukraine. So the Bolsheviks, you know, so you've got, I mean, basically you've got with the Russian Civil War, you've got the white armies who are czarists. You've got the Red Army, say the Bolshesheviks and then you've got a ukrainian nationalist army and they're all kind of well armies yeah armies they're all kind of charging
西方的大多数人对这一点也缺乏理解吗？我的意思是，基本上直到我研究这段时期之前，根据我对这段时期的理解，因为对我们西方人来说，经历了一战然后它就停了。但基本上对乌克兰来说，恐怖之处在于，1914年开始的恐怖时期，我的意思是，它持续了长达几十年的时间。因为本质上，一战演变为了俄国内战。但当时的俄罗斯包括了乌克兰很大的一部分。所以布尔什维克，你知道的，所以你拥有——基本上在俄国内战中，你拥有作为沙皇主义者的白军。你拥有红军，也就是布尔什维克，然后你拥有乌克兰民族主义军队，他们都在某种程度上——嗯，军队，军队——他们都在四处冲锋陷阵，互相攻击。所以为了让你对这一点有个概念，汤姆，基辅在两年内
around attacking each other so to give you a sense of this tom kiev in two years it it changed hands 16 times god so there's a brilliant novel by mikhail bulgakov called the white guard um that captures this and and basically you know there are just armies every few days there's a brilliant novel by Mikhail Bulgakov called The White Guard that captures this. And basically, you know, there are just armies. Every few days, there's a different army entering the city from a different direction and killing loads of people. There are horrific pogroms. There are some historians who argue, you know, the Holocaust in the sort of what Timothy Stein calls the bloodlands. That kind of gets going even before the Nazisis pitch so we should we should we haven't
易手了16次。天哪。所以米哈伊尔·布尔加科夫写过一部名为《白卫军》的出色小说，捕捉到了这一点。基本上，你知道，就是有各种军队。每隔几天——有一部由米哈伊尔·布尔加科夫创作的名为《白卫军》的出色小说捕捉到了这一点。基本上，你知道，就是有各种军队。每隔几天，就会有一支不同的军队从不同的方向进入这座城市，杀死大量的人。发生了可怕的大屠杀。有些历史学家认为，蒂莫西·斯奈德称之为“血土地”的地区中发生的犹太人大屠杀，甚至在纳粹登场之前就已经开始了。所以我们应该——我们还没有
mentioned the jews and ukraine is also one of the perhaps the great european center of jewish culture it is exactly so we mentioned levive um philip sands the human rights lawyer wrote an absolutely brilliant book called east west street about um the extermination of the Jews in Lviv, where he has a kind of his family history goes back to. And for those people who are interested, it really brings that alive. The Rat Line as well, his brilliant podcast series. The German commander who he's kind of trying to track down was the commander there, I think. That's right, exactly, yes.
提到犹太人，而乌克兰也是欧洲犹太文化的重要中心之一，确实如此。所以我们提到了利沃夫。人权律师菲利普·桑兹写了一本极其精彩的书，名叫《东西街》，讲述了利沃夫犹太人的灭绝，他的家族历史就可以追溯到那里。对于那些感兴趣的人来说，这本书真的让那段历史栩栩如生。还有他的精彩播客系列《老鼠路线》。他试图追踪的那个德国指挥官就是那里的指挥官，我想。没错，绝对是的，是的。
But the history of that is much, I mean, it goes back to the so the jews are kind of settling there through the 16th century 17th century 18th century this this incredibly vibrant culture east european culture so you know in a sense the kind of the idea that you have of east european culture is at least as much ukrainian as it is polish yes it is right i mean you know at least as much maybe more well because partly because those the the border between poland and ukraine is very messy you know there are people on either side of the border so so there's not a a distinct because their histories are rather like ukraine and and russia because their histories are so tightly interwoven but you do also have this tradition of a kind of occasional pogroms you do peasant peasants who um because jews are settled much
但那段历史要久远得多，我的意思是，它一直追溯到——所以犹太人在16世纪、17世纪、18世纪开始在那里定居，这种极其充满活力的东欧文化——所以从某种意义上说，你对东欧文化的印象至少有一半是乌克兰的，正如它是波兰的一样。是的，没错，我的意思是（你知道的）至少有一半，也许更多。好吧，部分原因是因为波兰和乌克兰之间的边界非常混乱，边界两边都有人，所以没有一个清晰的……因为他们的历史——就像乌克兰和俄罗斯一样——因为他们的历史交织得如此紧密。但你也确实拥有偶尔发生大屠杀的传统，你确实有这样的农民——因为犹太人更多地定居在村庄里，而不是田野里——然后在19世纪也是如此，我认为也有一些……所以这也是开始沸腾的这锅有毒汤料的一部分。
more in in villages than out in the fields uh and and then in the 19th century as well i think there are there are some so that's also part of this toxic brew that is starting to bubble up exactly yeah and actually the next few decades are a very grim story but one interesting point before we get into the grimness. Going back to Putin's remark about the Bolsheviks inventing Ukraine, that's clearly not the case because what happens in 1922 when they form the Soviet Union
完全是这样，是的。而且实际上，接下来的几十年是一个非常严峻的故事，但在我们陷入严峻之前有一个有趣的观点。回到普京关于布尔什维克发明了乌克兰的言论，这显然不是事实，因为1922年他们组建苏联时，
is basically even the Bolsheviks in Ukraine recognise that the national idea is now so strong that Ukraine cannot be admitted to the Soviet Union as merely part of Russia. Well, because the Ukrainians had just defeated the Red Army, right? I mean, you know, Ukrainian Nationalist Army had just defeated the Red Army,
基本上，甚至乌克兰的布尔什维克也认识到，民族理念现在如此强大，乌克兰不能仅仅作为俄罗斯的一部分加入苏联。嗯，因为乌克兰人刚刚击败了红军，对吧？我的意思是，（你知道的）乌克兰民族主义军队刚刚击败了红军，
even though they've now been swallowed up again. Yeah, because clearly the national idea, as all across Europe in the 1920s, as in Ireland, as in what becomes Czechoslovakia or what becomes Yugoslavia, the national idea is so strong and so powerful, you can't just crush it. And so that's why it becomes the Soviet Union. Right. Not the Russian Empire.
尽管他们现在又被吞并了。是的，因为很明显，这种民族理念，就像整个19世纪20年代的欧洲一样，就像爱尔兰一样，就像后来的捷克斯洛伐克或南斯拉夫一样，民族理念是如此强烈和强大，你根本无法将其粉碎。这就是为什么它变成了苏联。没错。而不是俄罗斯帝国。
And Ukraine is implicitly, well, not implicitly, explicitly acknowledged as a constituent kind of nation of the Soviet Union. I mean, maybe they wouldn't use the word nation. But then, obviously, everything is really horrible. So there's a famine in 1921, 22. And then Stalin launches collectivization at the beginning of the 1930s.
并且乌克兰暗含地——好吧，不是暗含地，是明确地被承认是苏联的一个组成民族。我的意思是，也许他们不会用“民族”这个词。但随后，很明显，一切都变得非常可怕。所以1921至1922年发生了饥荒。然后斯大林在20世纪30年代初发起了农业集体化。
So basically what's happening- And then there really is a famine. Yeah, so what's happening there is Ukraine has been the breadbasket of the Russian Empire. But Stalin wants to sell all that grain abroad to pay for industrialization because he thinks you have to industrialize because Marxist kind of logic demands it. And he wants to collectivize as well. I mean, wherever peasant farmers are collectivized, there is suffering.
所以基本上发生的事情是——然后真的发生了饥荒。是的，所以发生在那里的事情是，乌克兰一直是俄罗斯帝国的粮仓。但斯大林想把所有这些粮食卖到国外来支付工业化的费用，因为他认为你必须进行工业化，因为马克思主义的逻辑要求这样做。他也想进行集体化。我的意思是，无论在哪个地方对农民进行集体化，都会伴随着痛苦。
There is. Because there are more peasant farmers in Ukraine. Therefore, the scale of suffering in Ukraine is off the scale. It is. So about, I mean, let's say if about 5 million people died in the Soviet famine of the early 1930s, probably about 4 million of them were Ukrainians. This is the event known as the Holodmor yeah exactly and it's um you know it's a terrible uh it leaves this awful scar in the ukrainian national consciousness and particularly actually in the last sort of 30 or 40 years because it's been able to be talked about
确实如此。因为乌克兰有更多的农民，因此乌克兰遭受痛苦的规模是空前的。确实如此。所以大约——我的意思是，假设在20世纪30年代初的苏联饥荒中大约有500万人死亡，其中可能大约有400万人是乌克兰人。这就是被称为“乌克兰大饥荒”的事件，是的，完全是这样。而且它是一个可怕的事件——它在乌克兰民族意识中留下了这道可怕的伤疤，特别是实际上在过去大约30或40年里，因为在苏联统治下，你是不被允许更自由地谈论它的。
more freely under the soviet union you weren't really allowed to talk about it. And you certainly weren't allowed to talk about it as a distinctly Ukrainian tragedy because that was seen as kind of nationalism. But obviously, it's become a massive psychological element in modern Ukrainian identity. Sorry, Tom, I interrupted you. No, I interrupted you. But just on that, you said about how people weren't allowed under the Soviet Union to talk about it as being distinctively Ukrainian. And my understanding is that in the very early years of the Soviet Union, actually, Ukrainian self-expression is given license. So Ukrainian does start to be studied in schools, all that kind of thing.
而且你绝对不被允许把它当作一场独特的乌克兰悲剧来谈论，因为这被视为一种民族主义。但很显然，它已经成为现代乌克兰身份认同中一个巨大的心理要素。抱歉，汤姆，我打断你了。不，是我打断了你。但就这一点而言，你刚才说在苏联统治下人们不被允许将其称为独特的乌克兰事件，而我的理解是，在苏联的极早期，实际上乌克兰的自我表达是得到允许的。所以乌克兰语确实开始在学校里被教授，所有这类事情都是如此。
And then another way in which Stalinism is terrible for Ukraine is that he slams the brakes on that. Yeah. The big process of Russification again, the, the church in Ukraine, which, you know,
然后斯大林主义对乌克兰来说糟糕的另一个方面是，他对此踩了急刹车。是的。俄罗斯化的大进程再次出现，乌克兰的教会——你知道的，
is a key, key kind of vessel for Ukrainian national self-consciousness that gets very, very brutally repressed. And then under the great Terror of 37-38, Ukraine suffers disproportionately from that. Yeah, Stalin is such a strange character because, of course, he's Georgian. Ukraine and Georgia are the two most, how's the word, they're the two constituent parts of the Soviet Union, apart from Latvia, Lithuania, Estonia, which is swallowed up later. They're the two part constituent parts of the soviet union apart from latvia lithuania estonia which is swallowed up later they're the two parts of the initial soviet union that have the the strongest kind of national consciousness and starling comes from one of them
它是乌克兰民族自我意识的一个关键、关键的容器——遭到了非常、非常残酷的镇压。然后在1937至1938年的大清洗中，乌克兰遭受了不成比例的苦难。是的，斯大林是一个如此奇怪的人物，因为当然，他是格鲁吉亚人。乌克兰和格鲁吉亚是——怎么说呢——它们是苏联的两个主要组成部分，除了后来被吞并的拉脱维亚、立陶宛和爱沙尼亚之外。它们是苏联的两个组成部分——除了后来被吞并的拉脱维亚、立陶宛和爱沙尼亚之外，它们是最初苏联中拥有最强烈民族意识的两个部分，而斯大林就来自其中之一。
and perhaps because he's georgian he's much he's he's really intolerant actually of of nationalist sentiments so when he takes over effectively from lenin, or from the sort of, after the chaos surrounding that's followed Lenin's death, Stalin really crushes, you know, Ukrainian sentiment. And you see that kind of come and go throughout the history of the Soviet Union. There'll be periods when Ukrainianization comes back up, and then the authorities and the Kremlin kind of clamped down on it again um later dominic do you think that with with stalin and ukraine in the 30s um he's kind of consciously preparing for a war with what he would call the capitalist powers but increasingly you know that that would
也许正因为他是格鲁吉亚人，他实际上非常、非常不宽容民族主义情绪。所以当他实际上从列宁手中接权——或者从列宁死后随之而来的混乱中接权——之后，斯大林真正地粉碎了乌克兰的情绪。你会看到这种情绪在整个苏联历史中时隐时现。会有那么几个时期，乌克兰化重新抬头，然后克里姆林宫当局又会对其进行打压。嗯，多米尼克，你认为斯大林在30世纪（编者注：应为30年代）对乌克兰的做法，他是否在有意识地为与他所谓的资本主义列强的战争做准备，但越来越明显的是，那将会……
include germany and he knows that in a you know ukraine is the borderland that it's going to be in the front line and so therefore ukraine more than anywhere perhaps he he has to to be particularly brutal as he sees it yeah i think so prepare the so because it's the kind of it's the buffer for russia proper and you know if if you've just had a famine that has claimed four million people the beginning of the 30s. With the start of the Second World War and the declaration of war against the Soviet Union in 1941, fresh horrors, you know, of a comparable scale. Well, Stalin is paranoid about everybody, and he's right to be paranoid about Ukraine in a sense, because, as you say, fresh horrors will come.
包括德国在内，他很清楚乌克兰是边境地区，将会处于最前线，因此，他不得不比其他任何地方都表现得格外残酷，在他看来，是的，我也这么认为，所以要做好准备，因为这里是俄罗斯本土的缓冲地带，你知道的，如果你刚刚经历了一场夺走400万生命的饥荒，那是在30世纪（注：此处应为30年代）初。随着二战的爆发以及1941年对苏联宣战，你知道的，又一场规模相当的可怕灾难降临了。斯大林对所有人都充满偏执，从某种意义上说，他对乌克兰保持警惕是正确的，因为正如你所说，新的恐怖即将来临。
And that's partly when the Nazis invade in 1941, some Ukrainians welcome it because they, nationalists, welcome it. So the most famous example is a man called Stepan Bandera, who's, again, a real hate figure for kind of Russian nationalists. They see him as a fascist, as a Nazi, all this stuff. Because at first, he's very much pro, you know, the Germans invading. Thinks this is tremendous because this will allow them to be liberated from their kind of Russian yoke. I mean, this is a very familiar pattern in that sort of part of Europe,
这也是为什么部分乌克兰人在1941年纳粹入侵时表示欢迎，因为他们这些民族主义者对此表示欢迎。最著名的例子是一个叫斯捷潘·班德拉的人，他同样是俄罗斯民族主义者眼中彻头彻尾的讨厌鬼。他们把他视为法西斯、纳粹分子等等。因为一开始，他非常赞成德国人的入侵。他认为这太棒了，因为这能让他们从俄罗斯的统治下解放出来。我的意思是，在欧洲的那个地区，这是一种非常熟悉的模式，
in the Baltic states as well. Actually, he then turned against the Nazis later on. Well, because Hitler's terrible. I mean, his treatment of the Ukrainians is monstrous. Because what you think when you're Ukrainian is, well, we've had the most awful time under Stalin. I mean, it couldn't be worse than Stalin because so many people have died. The Germans are arriving, hurrah, because they think of the Germans from the First World War and they think, well, they were kind of our allies and stuff.
在波罗的海国家也是如此。事实上，他后来又反戈一击，反对纳粹。好吧，那是因为希特勒太可怕了。我的意思是，他对乌克兰人的虐待简直惨绝人寰。因为当你是一个乌克兰人时，你会想，我们在斯大林统治下已经经历过了最可怕的时期。我的意思是，情况不可能比在斯大林统治下更糟了，因为有那么多的人死去了。德国人来了，太棒了，因为他们想到了第一次世界大战时的德国人，他们觉得，好吧，他们算是我们的盟友之类。
The Nazis arrive, and yes, as you say, you know, the most horrendous, horrendous death toll. Hitler wants Ukraine as Lebensraum, as a place for germans to spread but he also wants to eliminate the jews tom well he well he yes he wants to eliminate the jews but he his his policy for dealing with the ukrainians is to kind of give them beads and i think to put up loud speakers in villages and play music every saturday so that the ukrainian peasants will come and dance and that'll keep them happy he He just thinks they'll be slaves, basically. They'll be, the Jews will be dead and the Ukrainians will be slaves. I mean, not as bad as the Poles though, right?
纳粹来了，正如你所说，带来了最可怕、最惨重的死亡人数。希特勒想要把乌克兰当作“生存空间”，作为德国人扩张的地方，但他同时也想消灭犹太人，汤姆。好吧，他——是的，他想消灭犹太人，但他对付乌克兰人的政策是给他们一些小恩小惠，我想，是在村子里架起扬声器，每个星期六播放音乐，这样乌克兰农民就会来跳舞，这就能让他们高兴。他只是觉得他们基本上就是奴隶。他们会——犹太人会死，而乌克兰人会成为奴隶。我的意思是，情况还没那么糟糕，比不上波兰人，对吧？
I mean, the Poles are kind of- Well, he has a particular, he has a hatred, he has a hatred of the Poles. I don't think he has a hatred of the Ukrainians, but he does regard them as inferior. And he thinks if they have this future, it's purely as kind of Slavic helots in this German, you know, new Germany, basically. And when we talk about the Nazi invasion of Russia, I mean, actually, Russia proper, not very much gets occupied, right? But the whole of Ukraine does.
我的意思是，波兰人有点——嗯，他有一种特殊的、他有一种仇恨，他仇恨波兰人。我不认为他仇恨乌克兰人，但他确实认为他们低人一等。他认为如果他们还有未来，那也纯粹是作为这个德国人、你知道的，崭新的德国版图中的斯拉夫奴隶存在。当我们谈论纳粹入侵俄罗斯时，实际上，俄罗斯本土并没有被占领太多，对吧？但整个乌克兰都被占领了。
Yeah. So the whole of Ukraine is under Nazi rule for kind of three years. Yeah. And the course of the future of the Second World War is decided, you know, all of these battles happen in Ukraine, but the most horrendous slaughter, the Red Army and the Wehrmacht going kind of back and forth, crushing, I mean, literally crushing villages beneath their tank tracks, civilians being killed. Of course, when you're occupied by one side or the other, your instinct is to collaborate with the occupiers just to get along. But that means if they then lose, the people who beat them will probably kill you or put you except that lots of ukrainians then join the red army when they come rolling back in they do yes so i i gather that um that more ukrainians died fighting with the red army than british french american casualties all put
是的。因此，整个乌克兰在纳粹统治下经历了大约三年。是的。第二次世界大战未来的走向由此决定，你知道的，所有这些战役都在乌克兰爆发，但最恐怖的屠杀是红军和德军来回拉锯，无情地碾压，字面意义上用坦克履带碾碎村庄，平民遭到杀害。当然，当你被某一方占领时，你的本能就是与占领者合作以求生存。但这意味着如果他们随后战败，击败他们的人可能会杀了你或者把你——除了许多乌克兰人在红军反攻回来时纷纷加入红军之外。确实是的，所以我了解到，嗯，在红军并肩作战中牺牲的乌克兰人比英、法、美三国的伤亡总数还要多。
together that's a good kind of amazing that's an incredible fact. Amazing fact. But what happens at the end of the war? I mean, 7 million people have been killed from Ukraine. And that's including the Jews killed in the Holocaust? Yeah. 10 million people have been left homeless. And basically, Ukraine has lost about half of its national wealth. I mean, when you think about how we go on in Britain, about the, I mean, go on.
加起来。这真是一个惊人的事实，令人难以置信的事实。惊人的事实。但战争结束时发生了什么？我的意思是，乌克兰有700万人丧生。这其中包含了在大屠杀中遇害的犹太人吗？是的。1000万人无家可归。基本上，乌克兰失去了大约一半的国民财富。我的意思是，当我们想到我们在英国是如何谈论的，关于——我的意思是，继续说。
I mean, that sounds like i'm being unduly self-flagellating when we think of the way we talk about what happened to coventry or london in the blitz or how americans talk about pearl harbor um and then you think about what happened to ukraine i mean it's just no it's in a different league i think it's so i think it's it's almost so numbing it's all it's and when you add to that the the famine that had happened 10 years previously yeah i mean it's the scale of the human suffering is kind of beyond comprehension it is i was about to say exactly the same it defies your brain seizes up it defies imagination it really defies imagination which is why it's so tragic the
我的意思是，这听起来像是在进行不必要的自我鞭笞，当我们回想我们是如何谈论考文垂或伦敦在闪电战中的遭遇，或者美国人如何谈论珍珠港时，然后你再想想乌克兰的遭遇，我的意思是，这根本——这完全不在同一个量级上。我觉得这几乎麻木到令人发指的地步，而且当你把这与10年后发生的饥荒结合起来看时，人类苦难的规模简直超乎想象。确实如此，我正要说同样的话，这彻底颠覆了你的大脑，超越了想象，真的超越了想象，正因如此，这一切才显得如此悲惨，
thoughts of it happening ever happening again um so tragic, the thought of it happening again. So anyway, before we sort of get too maudlin, it comes out of World War II, back in the Soviet Union. Stalin dies in 1953, and Nikita Khrushchev takes over. He had been the party boss in Ukraine in the late 1930s. He had orchestrated Stalin's purges there. Khrushchev was, you know, the sort of image of him sometimes that you get is this sort of round jolly man kind of exchanging quips with richard nixon khrushchev had quite a lot of blood on his hands however he was perhaps more sympathetic to ukraine than stalin was so we mentioned 1654 and that that landmark deal tom do you want to say his name again? Bogdan?
一想到这一切还会再次发生，就让人感到悲惨。所以，在我们变得过于多愁善感之前，二战结束后，苏联内部发生了变化。斯大林于1953年逝世，尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫接权。他在20世纪30年代末曾担任乌克兰党魁。他曾在那里一手策划了斯大林的清洗运动。赫鲁晓夫——你知道的，人们对他的印象有时是一个圆滚滚、喜气洋洋的人，和理查德·尼克松互相打趣。然而，赫鲁晓夫的手上也沾满了鲜血，不过，他可能比斯大林对乌克兰更有同理心。所以我们提到了1654年以及那个具有里程碑意义的协议，汤姆，你想再念一遍他的名字吗？博格丹？
I'll leave it to you. Bogdan Khmelnytsky, that he had struck as the Cossack leader with the Tsar. And to mark that moment for the 300th anniversary, Khrushchev gives Ukraine a present. And that present is Crimea. Now, of course, Crimea has always been, you know, its history has always been very closely related with that of the rest of Ukraine. But it has often been slightly separate because it was a different carnate and then because it was the headquarters of the Black Sea Fleet. And it was, you know, it's not full of, as it were, of former Ruthenians. It doesn't have quite the same history. So that creates a bit of a ticking time bomb, the award of Crimea. Although, to be fair, the Russians recognize it and make no fuss about it in the 1990s when Ukraine becomes independent.
这还是留给你吧。博格丹·赫梅利尼茨基，这是他作为哥萨克领袖与沙皇达成的协议。为了纪念300周年的那一刻，赫鲁晓夫送给乌克兰一件礼物。而这份礼物就是克里米亚。当然，克里米亚一直以来——你知道的，它的历史与乌克兰其他地区紧密相连。但它往往又有些许独立性，因为它曾是一个不同的汗国，后来又成了黑海舰队的总部。而且它，你知道的，不像以前那样挤满了鲁塞尼亚人。它的历史不尽相同。因此，赠予克里米亚这笔奖励埋下了一颗定时炸弹。尽管公平地说，在20世纪90年代乌克兰独立时，俄罗斯人承认了这一点，并没有大惊小怪。
So Dominic, just before we get onto that, two things about Ukraine and the Soviet Union after the war. One is they become a member of the United Nations, I think. They do, yeah. Very strange that that happens but again so that again undermines putin's argument that you know i mean the soviet union recognized it so so the ukraine is a member of the united nations even as a member of the soviet union the other of course the most famous thing that happens um in the soviet period in in uh ukraine after the war is chernobyl yeah 86 yeah massively important i think in discrediting the soviet leadership in creating a sense of
所以多米尼克，在我们切入正题之前，关于乌克兰和战后苏联有两件事。第一件事是，他们成为了联合国的成员，我想是的。确实是的，没错。这非常奇怪，但同样地，这也削弱了普京的论点，你知道的——我的意思是，苏联承认了这一点——所以乌克兰甚至作为苏联的一个成员国，也是联合国的成员。当然，战后苏联时期在乌克兰发生的另一件最著名的事件就是切尔诺贝利，是的，86年，是的。我认为这在抹黑苏联领导层、营造一种……方面具有极其重要的意义。
well it doesn't create a sense of ukrainian distinctiveness because it's always been there and actually there have been moments in between those in the preceding period so in particularly in the 60s and early 70s there'd been a kind bit of a Ukrainian revival and lots of books and journals published and people reviving the Ukrainian language and so on. But then Chernobyl happens. And that is a metaphor and a half, isn't it? It is. Absolutely, it is. It's a great cloud of radioactivity drifting across the air.
嗯，这并没有营造出一种乌克兰独特性，因为这种独特性一直都存在，而且在之前的时期，在这些事件之间其实也有过一些时刻，特别是在20世纪60年代和70年代初，曾出现过某种乌克兰复兴浪潮，出版了大量书籍和期刊，人们重新使用乌克兰语等等。但接着切尔诺贝利事件发生了。这绝对是一个绝佳的隐喻，不是吗？确实如此，绝对是的。那是一片在空中弥漫飘荡的巨大放射性云团。
Well, actually, most of the cloud the cloud tom ends up over belarus not over ukraine so it's belarus that is most scarred by chernobyl not ukraine but as you say it happens in ukraine that the authorities in moscow in the kremlin try to cover it up and deny it for so long this is gorbachev right you know it's not his predecessors um so it absolutely creates a sense of anger and a sense of you know it just compounds everything that has been growing for so long. And like the Holodomor, it's a massively important moment in Ukraine's sense of itself as distinct. And you see at the end, I mean, again, Putin in his speech basically says the Ukrainians didn't want independence. It was a terrible mistake that they became separate.
不过事实上，大部分云团——汤姆，云团最终飘到了白俄罗斯上空，而不是乌克兰上空。所以受切尔诺贝利影响最深、创伤最重的是白俄罗斯，而不是乌克兰。但正如你所说，它发生在乌克兰，而莫斯科和克里姆林宫的当局却试图掩盖并长期否认此事。这是戈尔巴乔夫时期，对吧？你知道的，这不是他前任们的事……所以这绝对引发了一种愤怒情绪，以及一种……你知道的，它彻底加剧了长期以来一直在积累的各种矛盾。就像大饥荒一样，这是乌克兰确立自身独特意识的一个极其重要的时刻。正如你最后所看到的，普京在讲话中基本上声称乌克兰人并不想要独立。他们走向分裂是一个可怕的错误。
This was all because of dreadful mistakes made by the Communist Party, i.e. Gorbachev, and the people around him. And it was all sort of top-down. That is, I mean, sorry to say, but that is, well, I'm not sorry to say it. I mean, that just is nonsense. There were demonstrations at the end of the 1980s in Lviv and Kiev by people calling for greater Ukrainian autonomy. There was new language law in 1989. So this is before the end of the Soviet Union in Ukraine,
这一切都是因为共产党，也就是戈尔巴乔夫及与其亲近的人犯下的可怕错误。这一切可以说是自上而下的。我的意思是——很抱歉这么说，但这绝对是——好吧，我不为这么说感到抱歉。我的意思是，这纯粹是无稽之谈。20世纪80年代末，利沃夫和基辅爆发了抗议示威，民众呼吁给予乌克兰更多的自治权。1989年通过了新的语言法。所以这是在苏联解体之前，在乌克兰境内，
generated from Kiev, saying they wanted Ukrainian to be the state language. There's a revive of the Union Church. There's an absolute sense at the end of the 1980s, as elsewhere in Eastern Europe, that the forces of kind of nationalism and national self-affirmation are gaining ground. And then you get the first calls for independence in 1990.
由基辅发起，要求将乌克兰语定为国语。乌克兰统一教会得以复兴。20世纪80年代末，正如东欧其他地方一样，人们有一种绝对的共识，即民族主义和民族自我肯定的力量正在取得优势。随后在1990年，便发出了最早的独立呼吁。
So that's before the coup against Gorbachev. Then the coup against Gorbachev happens. And then from that point, you know, Moscow seems to be in a complete and utter shambles and chaos. And the new head of the Communist Party in Ukraine is man called Leonid Kravchuk. And he basically, you know, like so many ex-communist leaders
所以这发生在针对戈尔巴乔夫的政变之前。接着针对戈尔巴乔夫的政变发生了。从那时起，你知道的，莫斯科似乎陷入了一片彻底的混乱与瘫痪之中。乌克兰共产党的新领导人是一个名叫列昂尼德·克拉夫丘克的人。他基本上，你知道的，就像许多东欧的前共产主义领导人一样，
across Eastern Europe, he thinks, well, the way to stay in power, really, is to work with this new force that's emerged, which is national identity and so on. So in December 1991, he has an independence referendum. I mean, you know, the idea that Ukrainian independence is this sort of mistake or this aberration. The independence movement, they win 90% of the vote. They win in every single oblast of Ukraine, including Crimea. the idea that there was some agreement that when the Russian leaders agreed to Ukrainian independence, one of the conditions was that they would remain within the Russian sphere of
他认为，要继续掌权，真正的方法是与这股新兴力量合作，也就是民族认同等等。所以在1991年12月，他举行了一次独立公投。我的意思是，你知道的，认为乌克兰独立是一种错误或反常现象的观点是站不住脚的。独立派赢得了90%的选票。他们在乌克兰的每一个州都获胜了，包括克里米亚。那种认为曾有过某种协议——即当俄罗斯领导人同意乌克兰独立时，条件之一是他们将留在俄罗斯的势力范围内，
influence and that they wouldn't join NATO and that the Americans would not try and suck it into the Western sphere of influence. Is that true, do you think? I think it's complicated, actually, Tom. I think there were sort of verbal assurances, I guess. I think given in the late 1980s and early 1990s, I think there were definitely Western statesmen who said to their Russian equivalents at the time, well, obviously, we have no intention of pushing NATO to Russia's borders, and that's not going to happen. And I don't think they said that disingenuously. I think they just didn't envisage it would happen. But then it was never written into a treaty.
且不会加入北约，而美国也不会试图将其拉入西方势力范围——这是真的吗？你觉得呢？汤姆，其实情况很复杂。我想当时确实有过某种口头保证。我认为在20世纪80年代末和90年代初，确实有一些西方政治家对他们的俄罗斯同行说过，很显然，我们无意将北约推到俄罗斯边境，这种事不会发生。我不认为他们说这话时居心叵测。我想他们只是根本没预料到这种情况会发生。但后来这从未被写进条约中。
It wasn't written into a treaty. Never a formal agreement. I mean, what was written into a treaty in 1994 was the so-called Budapest referendum. Now, that's where Ukraine had got some of Russia's, Soviet Union's nuclear weapons. And Ukraine said, we will give up these nuclear weapons as long as our borders are guaranteed. And one of the countries that was, it's a bit like the famous piece of paper, assuring Belgian independence in the 19th century that becomes the sort of Casus Belli for World War I. One of the countries that signed the guarantee of Ukraine's borders was Russia,
它并没有被写进条约。从未有过正式协议。我的意思是，1994年被写进条约的是所谓的《布达佩斯备忘录》。当时，乌克兰拥有俄罗斯、苏联的一些核武器。而乌克兰表示，只要我们的边境得到保障，我们就会放弃这些核武器。其中一个签署国——这有点像19世纪那张著名的保证比利时独立的纸条，后来成了第一次世界大战的开战理由——签署保障乌克兰边境的国家之一就是俄罗斯，
Boris Yeltsin's Russia. So if there was a moment to say, well, actually, the borders aren't quite right, we're not happy with them, that was 1991, or between 1991 and 1994. Yeltsin was drunk, I guess. Well, Yeltsin was obviously hammered the whole time. Russia was in an absolute mess.
鲍里斯·叶利钦的俄罗斯。所以，如果当时有什么时候可以说“实际上，这些边界不太对劲，我们对它们很不满意”，那就是1991年，或者在1991年至1994年之间。我猜叶利钦当时喝醉了吧。好吧，叶利钦当时显然一直在烂醉如泥。俄罗斯当时正处于绝对的混乱之中。
Ukraine, by the way, was also in an absolute mess. I mean, Ukraine actually, unbelievably, did even worse in the 1990s than Russia did. Ukraine lost 60% of its GDP. I mean, that's- That's a lot. That's a recession and a half. Its inflation rate was in the tens of thousands. I mean, it has suffered this utter economic meltdown, not least because, as we said earlier on, the Donbass and places like that, it's heavy industry, coal, steel.
顺便说一句，乌克兰当时也处于绝对的混乱之中。我的意思是，难以置信的是，乌克兰在20世纪90年代的经济表现实际上比俄罗斯还要糟糕。乌克兰失去了60%的国内生产总值（GDP）。我的意思是，这——这真是太严重了。这是一场史无前例的严重衰退。其通货膨胀率高达数万个百分点。我的意思是，它经历了这场彻底的经济崩溃，很大程度上是因为，正如我们刚才所说，顿巴斯及类似地区是以重工业、煤炭和钢铁为主的。
It's dying out. It's doomed. I did a geography project on it at school. Of course you did. You know all about Donetsk. I do. I do. I can still draw a little map of it.
它正在消亡。它注定要走向毁灭。我上学时还做过一个关于它的地理项目。你当然做过。你对顿涅茨克了如指掌。我确实知道。我甚至还能画出它的小地图。
Yeah, but you can't say Bogdan Karnitsky. No, but I can say pig iron. Okay, well, that's good. That's what it was all about. Yeah, so Ukraine's history since independence has obviously been tortured. It's been very difficult. They've had the Orange Revolution in 2004. They then had the Euromaidan movement in 2014, which is basically the sort of popular uprising against the pro-Russian President Yanukovych because he wouldn't sign a deal with the EU.
对，但你连“博格丹·赫梅利尼茨基”都念不出来。不，但我能说出“生铁”这个词。好吧，那挺不错的。这正是关键所在。是的，所以乌克兰自独立以来的历史显然是饱经沧桑的。非常艰难。他们在2004年经历了橙色革命。随后在2014年又经历了“尊严革命”（欧迈丹运动），这基本上是一场反对亲俄总统亚努科维奇的民众起义，因为他拒绝签署与欧盟的协议。
And that then triggered Putin's annexation of Crimea and then the fermenting of separatism in Donetsk and Luhansk. And now we are kind of where we are. Yeah. Yeah. Well, yeah. I mean, it's not a cheery story, really. It's not. And I think that's what makes the the the
这随后引发了普京对克里米亚的吞并，以及在顿涅茨克和卢甘斯克煽动分裂主义。于是我们便走到了今天的地步。是的。好吧，是的。我的意思是，这实在算不上一个令人愉快的故事，真的不算。我认为正是这一点让人感到……
you sort of feel like i mean you don't wish a war and invasion on anybody i mean that would that would be demented i wouldn't even wish on the french tom but uh but if there's one people in europe who probably say yeah who deserve who really do deserve a break um they are the ukrainians and i sort of i think it's it's tragic that they that they are in this um they're in this position now anyway we it is we said we wouldn't get maudlin so we shouldn't no um so we hope you've enjoyed that um obviously we've we've put this out because of the um you know the situation that we've we've just arrived at after our sweep through ukrainian history um we do have as we've mentioned already uh two other podcasts touching on this theme so there's the um
你会有一种感觉——我的意思是，你不会希望任何人遭受战争和入侵，那未免太疯狂了。我甚至都不会希望法国人遭遇这种事，汤姆。但是，如果说欧洲有哪一个民众可能理应得到一个转机、真正值得拥有一个喘息之机的话，那就是乌克兰人了。我觉得他们落入这样的境地真是太悲剧了，他们现在处在这样的境地……无论如何，我们之前说过不会变得多愁善感，所以我们不应该这样。那么，希望大家喜欢这期节目。显然，我们推出这期节目是因为我们刚刚经历的局势，在回顾了乌克兰历史之后，正如我们已经提到的，我们还有另外两期涉及这一主题的播客，其中一期是……
the two episodes that we did on the vikings in the east we did and then there is the episode that we did during the euros when um each time time England played a team, we would look at the history of England's relationship with that country. And of course, England played Ukraine, beat them in Rome. And so you'll find the top episodes joining English and Ukrainian history as well. And I think we are going to put them up. If you have a look at, at wherever you get this podcast, Spotify or iTunes or whatever, you will see them immediately listed immediately after this at the top of the list of episodes that we've recorded.
我们做的关于东方维京人的两期节目，是的，还有我们在欧洲杯期间制作的那期节目。当时，英格兰每对阵一支球队，我们就会回顾英格兰与那个国家关系的的历史。当然，英格兰对阵过乌克兰，并在罗马击败了他们。所以你也会找到将英格兰和乌克兰历史联系在一起的精选节目。我想我们会把它们置顶。如果你在收听这个播客的任何平台上查看，无论是Spotify、iTunes还是其他平台，你都会看到它们紧随其后地列在我们录制节目列表的最顶部。
So if you listen to, if you haven't already listened to those, we hope you'll enjoy them. Well, Dominic, it's yeah. Yeah. Sober stuff,
所以如果你还没听过那些节目，希望你会喜欢。好吧，多米尼克，这真是……是的。真是沉重的话题，
sober stuff, very sober stuff. Let's hope, well, I mean, let's hope it's, yeah. Yeah. Sober stuff. Sober stuff. Very sober stuff. Let's hope, well, I mean. Let's hope it all sorts out. Yeah, like it will. Yeah. Right. We shall be back.
沉重的话题，非常沉重的话题。让我们希望，好吧，我的意思是，让我们希望……是的。沉重的话题。沉重的话题。非常沉重的话题。让我们希望，好吧，我的意思是。让我们希望这一切都能解决。是的，就像它会解决的那样。好吧。我们稍后会回来。
If you want to cheer yourself up, you should listen to our episode about the top 10 parties, disastrous parties in human history. There's quite a lot of death and mayhem in that. There is, but the fate. Not on quite the same scale. It would be hard to listen to the fate of diedrich graf von what's his name i can't remember but but it features a hoover hazel or whatever his name is that's all we'll say without without um cracking a smile and next week we have uh an episode on um the most uh calamitous
如果你想让自己高兴起来，你应该听听我们关于人类历史上最糟糕的10次派对的节目。那期节目里有很多死亡和混乱。确实如此，但命运。规模没那么大。要了解迪特里希·格拉夫·冯……叫什么名字来着？我记不清了，但他身边有个叫胡佛·黑泽尔什么的家伙，这就是我们所能说的，而不会……破涕为笑。下周我们将推出一期节目，讲述……
things that you could wear the things that um over the course of the history of fashion have caused the most casualties um and also we have um a couple of episodes uh basically posing question of when did the roman empire fall uh and we haven't actually recorded that yet but i suspect very much suspect for reasons i won't go into now that um that the crimea will feature in that as well so uh there will be a further touch of the Crimea in an episode on the Roman Empire next week. So if you've enjoyed this, I hope you will enjoy that as well. And in the meanwhile, goodbye.
你在时尚史上能穿的最灾难性的服饰，也就是在时尚史的发展过程中造成最多伤亡的那些东西；此外，我们还有几期节目，基本上提出了“罗马帝国是何时灭亡的”这一问题。我们其实还没录制这期节目，但我非常怀疑——出于我暂且不谈的原因——克里米亚也会在其中占据一席之地。所以，下周关于罗马帝国灭亡的节目中，还会带有克里米亚的痕迹。如果你喜欢这期节目，希望你也会喜欢那一期。在此期间，再见。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取加更节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。